all right everybody
here we go we are
live and so
march q a there's a lot of people who
already sent some super chat so
all right so for people who haven't been
here before the way we do this is
uh people um who are subscribed to me
at 10 or more get to ask questions in
advance and so i'm going to go through
their questions
and then at the end if i still have
energy and time
i usually do i think i've been getting
better at it i will
then go through the super chats and uh
and then look at those
i sadly i can't answer questions
directly in the chat just because
just the way i'm doing it now i already
have like 40 questions and so
i can't really it's very difficult for
me to follow the chat
and so happy to see that some of my
moderators are there jacob
is there brad is there wonderful
dork robbins neil is there wonderful
all right and so
we're ready to start i i guess i have a
few things i need to deal with first
so as so what i'm doing in these in
these
uh months is because of the pressure on
social media
we are uh i'm what i want to do is i
really want to encourage people to sign
up to the website because if things go
south and youtube gets weirder
then we will have people's emails and we
can
we can uh still publish on um on bit
shoot or on other platforms
and still be able to stay in contact
with you so so i'm really encouraging
people to sign up to the website
um and there's a you can go down to the
bottom of the website it's a free you
just write your email in there and then
you'll start to get
notifications when things come out and
that'll be helpful too
as the website gets more interactive i'm
working on that now with them with uh
with a marketing company to get have it
have maybe forums on the website
to have more content uh more integration
with the different articles that people
are writing all of that
is is happening so sign up and
so all right so what i'm doing to
encourage people to sign up is i'm doing
a raffle
with with some merchandise that i design
so last month
i was going to uh i'm go i was
raffling a a uh six day of creation
t-shirt nice gray t-shirt and then
also a uh
a little griffin t-shirt and so
the people who won drum roll i guess i
can't do a drum roll
so the person who won the uh the six
days t-shirt is
named odie so i don't know i don't know
it's just odi
so anyway though you'll get an email and
uh for for me to get your address
and the next person who won is named
lindsay gale and uh him or her
i don't know if it's a man or woman won
the griffin t-shirt so
next month so sign up this month and the
next month i'm giving like the jackpot i
i'm even hesitating
to raffle these because i want to keep
them for myself uh
so the first one is going to be uh it's
going to be an all-over
print uh st michael t-shirt uh
medium-sized
and so it's got the nice all-over site
michael and it's gonna be a st
michael saint michael theme and then the
second one is actually going to be a
zip up hoodie with say michael on the
back
and with the nice little six days of
creation on the front so that's the big
that's the big one
all right so uh so sign up to the
website and oh as i as i forgot to tell
you
so what i'm doing just to make it fair
for everybody uh everybody who signs up
gets
one chance and then uh patrons anybody
who's a patron at any level
gets two chances so that's how i'm doing
it
all right so here we go so there are a
lot of things that are coming
in the in the pipeline as you know
i guess the jordan peterson video came
out and so this month we reached 100 000
subscribers and it's still going up 104
000 so thank you to everybody who
subscribed everybody who is
involved in the symbolic world community
uh i'm really excited
as to where this can go um
and so i i asked a lot of people what
they wanted me to do for the hundred
thousand subscribers and i got
some answers some of them sadly are
impossible the biggest one was the at
formats here to come and uh be on the on
the uh
on the on the website again or to be on
youtube with me again
and so i asked him just out of formality
but he didn't answer because i know he
doesn't want to be on screen anymore so
maybe one day who knows but at least for
now that's not happening
and so what i did is the next one was
people asking about to do videos on
revelation
so i started a series on revelation i
did one
on the mark on the sim on the system of
the beast let's say
there's going to be another one on the
mark of the beast that i'm working on
now and maybe a third one i'm not sure
how i'm going to do it whether
a patron on the video or maybe for
everybody will be on the two women on
the [ __ ] of babylon
and the mother that that flees to the
desert so it'll be like those three
themes for revelation
and i also did a live stream
of my carving which is a lot of people
asked for that and i'm really surprised
because
i kind of i said okay well i can do a
live stream of carving so i just did it
and then
i think like 10 000 people ended up
watching it which is which is really
surprising
uh so i probably will do that again um
i'm actually right now preparing a
online carving class
and so i've been super busy in the past
few weeks putting it together
i filmed everything with three cameras
and have been just been editing
non-stop and so it's almost ready i
think i'm going to drop it next week
it's going to be a wood carving class an
icon of
saint john the foreigner saint john the
baptist we're going to start with that
icon and i'm going to try to have three
courses
one an icon of saint john one of the
mother of god the
virgin mary and then one of christ in
the center it's called the day assist
it's like the
one of the basic structures of
iconography and so we're going to
i'm going to do them separately so three
courses um so look out for that
next week i think i'm going to uh to
drop it for people who would like
to spend a lot of time with me icon
carving because
i really film every step and i talk
through them so it's a lot of hours
to uh to learn to carve an icon so i'm
excited about all that stuff
so there's a lot of stuff i'm sure there
are things that i'm forgetting oh yeah
also the french
podcast has been going for
i guess maybe about a month a bit more
than a month we have three episodes out
so if you speak french go to the french
channel uh jonathan
and sign up with jp marco we are
we we started an introduction we did an
episode on zombies and
this one the last one was on heaven and
earth and we're going to just keep going
with uh with the themes the symbolic
themes
so yeah so just a bunch of stuff going
on and
all right so here we go so i'm gonna
usually i end like starting with the
website
and so yeah so people who support me
support me through three platforms
the website and on patreon and also i'm
subscribed star but there aren't a lot
of people
left on subscribe star because
it's not a it's not a great platform um
all right okay so here we go with the
website
so david markham asks do do you think
you'll ever team up
with an icon painter writer and create
painted carved icons
uh yeah maybe i've been thinking about
that but what
probably end up doing is i'll probably
end up doing it myself
um if i end up painting them but i it's
funny i haven't really had
any patrons ask for that yet i'm kind of
hoping one day someone will
so if ever that happens if ever that
happens i i
keep reminding myself that i'm not
taking i'm not taking any orders anymore
but in a few years if someone asks for
that i will probably
be happy to do it um
so nomad in socks says it was very
helpful to me when you use the word
decompress
when referring to what you are doing
when you pull out the concepts of a
symbol
and then put them into a specific
relatable perspective for us
my question is you have any insight into
the reverse of that process
what process is compressing these
symbols in the first place
did i even use that word i don't
remember using that word i know i use
the word compress a lot
in the sense that the notion of compress
or at least the way that i understand
when i talk about a compression it means
that
imagine there are uh all right imagine
your day so you have a bunch of things
that happen to you during the day
and actually there's an indefinite
amount of things that happen to you
during the day but let's say there's a
more definite amount of things that
happen to you
that you can actually pay attention to
all right so out of that
amount of things you can pay attention
to there's a number of things that
you'll remember
right and then out of those things that
you remember there are a number of
things that you're going to
use to put together into a narrative to
tell the story of your day to your
spouse
so that's the that's how symbolism works
there's a compression
of factuality into a
symbolic structure and so once you get
to the story part once you get to the
part where you're actually telling the
story of your day
to your spouse that has to be organized
in a certain way
for it to be interesting to that other
to that person so
in that desire to organize the facts in
an interesting manner
you'll end up with something which will
have a universal
uh symbolic structure and the closer it
is to the universal symbolic
will kind of just flow by or the person
will find it boring we'll find it
uninteresting or
or we'll just forget it right away and
so that's what i mean when i talk about
compression is is that's how symbolism
works and so
my contention is that that can happen at
different levels and know so not just at
individual levels but it can happen at
let's say national levels
at you know at uh tribal levels at
different
levels this type of compression can have
and then they can also happen at a
cosmic level
and that's what you find let's say in
the early stories in scripture
it's like it's like a cosmic compression
of facts that have taken
you know huge huge huge amounts of
information
or or rather extremely important
information
and has compressed it in a way so that
we we
even thousands of years later can still
attend to it and can still remember it
and so that it has a certain effect on
the way that you
organize things and even the slant or
the words or the concepts that end up
shifting and moving in order to actually
communicate
the the thing you're trying to
communicate and then sometimes being
being a um let's say being exact
is not the best way to do it that there
are there are actually other types of
storytelling that are not exact in the
way that we think of
kind of scientific exactness which would
be better to tell that story
um and so that's what that's my
contention about it so my contention is
that
for example the store in scripture are
all talking about events like none of
them are just someone who's
sat there and made it up they're
actually talking about events but
they're doing it
more and more especially as you move
toward genesis more and more in a
compressed
fashion so that once you get to like the
creation narrative you've got like the
entire cosmos
compressed into this one narrative which
is so
full that you know that that it's a it's
mind-blowing if when you start to unpack
it
and so yeah so maybe maybe i use the
word decompress when i explain it and so
when i'm explaining it i am definitely
doing a form of decompression
in the sense that i'm picking apart the
this this structure and i'm showing you
aspects of it so that you can
be able to see it let's say happen
all right so roxanne asks what is the
church's role in reforming the state in
kansas city
the heartland presbytery sent a letter
to the board of police commissioners
asking that the police chief be
dismissed
this seems to me to cross a line of
propriety thank you
and may your lent be blessed and so
the way to understand it is that there
there is a normal relationship
between uh let's say religious authority
and temporal power it's probably the
best way to
to describe it is that religion doesn't
have
it's not supposed to let's say have uh
means of coercion like they they don't
have police and that
don't have armies they don't have swords
they don't have weapons
what they have is influence and
authority right they have spiritual
influence
and so it is it is inevitable that at
some point
this the religious authority will try to
influence the political sphere through
its
means let's say and so it doesn't always
happen in the best way but that's the
idea is that they'll put
pressure a kind of spiritual pressure a
pressure
also uh in their in the fact that the
people are attached to them
right and so the trust that the people
have for the religious authorities
the more the religious authorities let's
say are
are straight or are are right or on the
right path
the more people will trust them and then
the more authority they will have to
press
to press down on the uh the uh political
authority and so that's the way it
happens that way and then the political
authority what it what it has is it has
doesn't have legitimacy in itself it's
only legitimacy is
is power and when it that's all the
legitimacy it has
it it tends to devolve into tyranny but
if it takes its legitimacy from the
spiritual authority
that is it's it you know in really in
the image of the byzantine
uh let's say the the um the bishop that
crowned the king uh then then
it will have a more balanced capacity
let's say to rule over the people
because it will obey the spiritual
commandments but it's really not it's
not weird like it's
completely reasonable it's like if the
if the political authority doesn't
respect spiritual
rules or becomes immoral becomes corrupt
uh and
and becomes tyrannical then then
they will lose the support of the church
and then ultimately they will also lose
the support of the people
and then but then it can also go the
other way right and so if the
if the spiritual authority becomes
corrupt then it will lose the support of
the people
and ultimately it will lose its capacity
to influence the political sphere
and so so these things happen in every
direction right
but ultimately the the idea is that the
body or what's at the bottom or the
the the the people the mass
they act as a support right they they
are kind of like a body
that attaches itself to the to to these
different identities
and depending on how they act they will
trust or mistrust
the authorities um and so it's a game
really and it's a game that's not always
super it's a game that can become
disturbing and annoying but that's the
game
the the other game uh is is a dangerous
one
and so i mean if the police commissioner
did something completely immoral then
in a way in a normal society it would be
the church's role to
ask for the police commissioner to to be
dismissed
um because that's the role of the church
the role of the church is to point out
the moral ideal that the state should
follow
um but of course this can be corrupted i
don't know the specific details of your
of the story it can be corrupted and uh
of course
all right so so pneuma asks any thought
on the concept of
messiah ben josef
i mean yeah that you could you could
think right in in um
hebraic thinking or in judea thinking
there's the the messiah the son of david
and the messiah son of joseph
and it really is kind of two aspects of
the messiah
in a way you could say it's kind of like
two opposite aspects
of the messiah where they kind of meet
together and they meet together in
christ obviously
in christ christ unites both the messiah
son of joseph and the messiah son of
david
but the idea is that you have one who is
you know the the king
the little one who kind of becomes the
king the surprise
uh change and then become the king and
then establishes jerusalem
as the holy city so he really is this
image of the king and then you rather
have the messiah son of joseph
who is the one who is rejected by his
people
and then ends up in the foreign land and
saves the foreigner
and so so david king david
saves israel right establishes jerusalem
saves
israel whereas joseph saves first goes
to the foreigner becomes a foreigner
right
becomes dressed up as a foreigner and
ultimately ends up saving
the egyptians to to a point where
he's not recognized by his own people
and then ultimately in the end it all
kind of comes together where he saves
both
the egyptians and his own people and so
that's one of the reasons why you have
all these stories right you have all
these stories about
this this kind of eschatological image
of of how the jews rejected jesus
and he went to rome he converted the
romans he got dressed as a roman if you
look at icons of christ he's dressed as
a roman
here is the messiah son of joseph he's
he he's disguised as a roman
and he saves the romans while his own
people
reject him and then ultimately the the
idea would be that in the end there
would be this recognition that he was
the messiah all along
that he was their son all along but you
know i mean who am i to tell the future
so so gary newellia
sorry if i'm pronouncing that wrong ask
why is wisdom sophia
personified as feminine
and so well you're gonna get me into
trouble is what you're gonna do but
that's okay that's okay
i don't mind answering this uh and so
you can understand
at least at least in the text in the old
testament text where it talks about uh
sophia
there is a sense in which it is
the house it's related to the house
the house of the lord and so there is a
there is this kind of
uh it is if it is at least in the old
testament it really does appear
as a kind of feminine version or a
feminine consort to the masculine aspect
of
of god and so you you have this kind of
call and response
between this this and so you can
understand it
like uh you know that you have the
bottom part of the equation right you
have the temple you have the ark of the
covenant
i talk about this all the time you have
the people you have the the you know the
uh
the church the ecclesia right the
gathering of the people and then you
have the glory of god which descends
on on that body on that support and so
you can understand
sophia as this capacity to kind of build
the house
in that sense in the old testament so
that's why it says wisdom built
her house right he made the space made
the temple
created this space which is appropriate
for the union with the the divine
and so that's why sophia is personified
as feminine
but it's a very fraught question in
terms of the the modern interpretation
because some people have gone very far
by identifying sophia with the virgin
mary and then
pushing that very far and then having
this idea of like
how there's this there's a fourth
hypostasis
of god and it becomes extremely fraught
and so i would say for now those
questions are probably
best not to be pried down pride into
too much and i say that all the time
like there's something about the
feminine
which should not be uttered there's
something about the feminine which
should remain a secret and should remain
uh
not a secret in the in the sense that
we're hiding it from people and the
secret in the sense
something which is kept for for
this the intimate encounter and is not
meant to be shown to the world and
kind of exposed to the world and so and
there are some things which when they're
shown to the world
become vulgar become this they become
denatured
and so i think the whole mystery of the
feminine uh
in relationship to god is something of
that where
it becomes denatured as soon as people
start to talk about too much
talk too much about it so i need to now
take my own advice
and stop talking about it
all right i know some say it's not true
christian doctrine but what is your view
on the symbolism
of the rapture and so i think it's just
not
interesting it's just not it's just not
christian it's not a christian
it's not at all a christian uh vision i
don't
um yeah
it's it's it's a total it's a complete
misunderstanding of
of revelation in my opinion and it's
also a
a very deep misunderstanding a very deep
misunderstanding in the sense of
a misunderstanding of the narrative
structure of the story
uh because in that then the narrative
structure of the story
it doesn't really make sense this idea
that
that god will like take you know take
the
the the faithful up into the sky or
whatever
um and that it doesn't it doesn't make a
lot of sense
but there is this sense that we will be
raised and we will meet christ in heaven
right that imagery all the imagery
that's used to kind of
to in create this rapture theology is
completely appropriate it's completely
it's it's very good to kind of
understand this idea that we
that we will rule with christ in the
heavens that we will
that it is possible for those of us who
are
in him to to to enter into the heaven
and to participate in the in the divine
council and participate in the
the rule you know to be above and then
now to have authority to
on what is below and so all of that is
is
is real it's just the rapture is just
kind of this
superficial thing
all right so gardner brothers in lord of
the rings what is the symbolism of frodo
using golem as a necessary god through
mordor in spite of golem's constant
deception and murderous resentment
towards sam
and so the way that i understand it is
that really frodo and golem are kind of
like
a mirror image or you can imagine golem
as
what frodo could become this vision of a
dead frodo let's say
um and so that's what that's kind of how
i see golem
and so there is this you could say that
you could say that that there is a kind
of
how can i say that there's a wisdom in
knowing yourself right or there's a
wisdom in understanding
where you can go and i think that that
there's something of that going on there
which is
really how because golem
is dead and because he is let's say of
mordor or not
directly but let's say symbolically he
is he is a mortar then he knows the way
there he knows the way to get to the
dark place and to be able to to get rid
of the ring
and so and so there's something about
that
in terms of your own self that you can
also
understand which is that if you are
aware of your dark
side if you are aware of your passions
if you're aware of your weaknesses if
you are aware
of your
your sins really uh then those sins can
teach you something
right they can actually teach you
something about how to
vanquish sin right if you know the
process by which you
sin if you kind of become aware of it
and you and you're able to follow it in
the sense
of not follow it in the sense of being
led blindly by it like falling into sin
but rather follow the process by which
you sin
so that when you get to the end you can
toss the sin into the pit
rather than fall right and so of course
frodo doesn't totally succeed that
but you can kind of understand how that
can be applied to your life
you know um like if you have a bad habit
like i've talked about this before
to understand the mechanisms by which
you end up falling back into this bad
habit
can help you right see it coming from
far away
and be able to follow it to its
end and know before you come to the end
right not to give in but rather to throw
the sin
into the fire to to to to to vanquish on
your passion
and so that's what i think it's about
all right and so so
blank asked could you discuss the
symbolism of jeremiah 17
9 the heart is deceitful above all
things
desperately wicked who can know it
how does this relate to follow the heart
and to the prayer of the heart etc
also if you want a short question is
your family christian your parents your
wife your crit
et cetera thank you for everything um
and so uh how does that relate to follow
the heart
and there's a better like that question
your question is a little fraught in the
sense that
that and that verse is not i don't know
if that's the best translation for it
because i know that
there is there's a the the word i think
for deceit was something like tortuous
in the sense of like
almost like a labyrinth right that's why
it says who can know it
in the sense that it's not necessarily a
moral question it's rather
a question of of not of having this like
this torturous aspect to the heart which
you can't which means that it's
veiled or that you can't really know it
that's at least my understanding of that
verse
but maybe i'm wrong but that's what i
that's what i've learned about it
but there is your question the basis of
your question or the basic aspect of
your question
i think is valid and you can see it in
the words of christ which is that christ
says
right it's not what goes into the to the
body that is
that is evil it's what comes out of the
heart which is evil you think okay
so yeah so then how does that fit uh to
following your heart into the prayer of
the heart et cetera and so
the way to understand this is through
fractals it's
it's through fracta fractal the fractal
nature of reality
uh and if you're interested in that idea
gave a talk about this
um i forget what it's called it was
something about
it was something like the mystical
the mystical nature of reality i forget
what the name of the talk was it was the
talk i gave in seattle
um where i talk about this and the idea
is that you need to understand the heart
as being a microcosm of everything
and so the heart even the heart itself
is is made of a little heaven and a
little earth
and so you can understand that it's like
there's the heart and then there's like
the heart of hearts you could say and
then you could you
know how far you could go the heart of
heart of hearts and so every
layer of the heart has a microcosm in it
it has an above and a below and it also
has
a center and a periphery and so you
could have this idea that
the serpent is in the garden right so
even in the garden of eden that's how it
works in the garden so
the garden of eden has a tree
and the image we show of it right with
the with the snake turning around the
tree
but that snake turning around the tree
is the same snake
that's it around the entire cosmos right
it's the same snake the leviathan that's
at the bottom of the ocean even
you know in scripture he's actually
described that way and so you can
imagine that that structure is also in
your heart that in your heart
there's also this center but then
there's also the possibility of this
periphery
or this or this uh deceitfulness or this
this labyrinth around that makes
it makes it what it is but also means
that
you're let's say the danger of sinning
starts in the heart
and so it starts in the heart and then
it
actually kind of uh reverberates into
reality just like the sin
started in the garden and then because
the world is a fractal structure
then the effects of the garden then
reverberate out into reality
and so that's the best way that i
understand it
all right so david flores
asked in the cosmic mystery of jesus
christ saint maximus discusses
logoe or logi it seemed to me that he
was indicating
that as we name define mediate with
logoi the logoe
also do the same for us similar to how
a background defines a figure or the
opposite of something
gives shape to its antithesis
uh is this a correct understanding of
his you
on logo so i would have to see like what
it is you're talking about in terms of
what he
says um uh
and so but i would say i mean do the
logoe affect
us of course they do because these these
essences that exist in the world
you know constitute us and constitute
aspects of us and constitute
aspects of the world in which we exist
and so they will definitely affect us as
well
right it's not just us who let's say
name but we also become
then we live in this world of identities
and so we have to live with them
so i don't think that's what you mean
but i'm not totally sure
uh how the idea of background defines
the figure i mean
there is this idea that identity always
has an outside so i don't know if that's
what you mean
in the sense that all identities uh
necessitate that they are let's say
manifested as in relation to other
identities so they always have an
outside so i don't know if that's what
you mean
like the outside would define the inside
as well
um so sorry about that if i don't
totally understand
all right since you will so josh the
mover asked since you will read this
question around the time
that the old calendar commemorates st
patrick of ireland the question seems
fitting what is a proper orthodox
understanding
of the concept of luck is it nothing
more than a heretical superstition that
denigrates the concept of grace or is
there something more to it
is luck a tiny miracle
so the way to understand luck is really
the way it is the idea of lots it's the
idea of a breakdown in reason
or a breakdown in causality
and this is what's difficult i guess is
that the breakdown in causality
of normal causality happens below and
above
right sometimes i talk about this like
the upper higher waters in the lower
waters is an image that you can
understand
and so for example so luck or chance
is used in games it's used in games of
chance to win
money uh it's used uh and it becomes
there's a passion element to it right
this this idea of giving yourself to
luck or giving yourself the chance
you know uh in in a game of chance for
example gambling all of that stuff
there is something passionate about it
and something which shows
the shows the lack of
supremacy of the system it's one of
those things the breakdown of causality
which shows how the system can't contain
everything
because you can decide things and you
can
get things or you can lose things based
on pure chance based on no
causality of your action in the sense of
right in the sense of like i work
and i dig a hole and then someone gives
me five dollars to dig the hole it's
like that's a
normal causality of reality whereas you
know i throw
i throw uh a die and then all of a
sudden i win money
it's like there's no there's no work
there right it's it's like the
it's the end of work let's say but
there's also a version
of of lot or luck
or chance which is above and so
and it has to do with uh in the old
testament it has to do with actually
discerning the will of god so the
the you know the um what are they called
the
uram and poor what do they call it i
think is that it
or something i forget the name of them
but the uh the breastplate of the
of the priests the uh the ephod had
these stones that could be used to to
to throw they would throw the stones
they don't know exactly how they would
do it but
they would use the stones in a way in a
kind of uh
chance manner in which to discern the
will of god and then they would pick
them
pic pic they would they would say like
this is what god is showing us
uh in the same way in the new testament
for example they picked the new
apostle uh based on lots and you see
that also even today someone told me
a bishop told me that in the orthodox
uh i don't know if it's there in every
orthodox church but at least in the oca
when they're choosing a new bishop uh
they will deliberate and they will
deliberate on who to choose
and uh if they all agree to choose one
person for the next bishop then they
will
then they will just vote him in but if
they don't agree and if they come at a
at a standstill then they will actually
use lots
and it is the lot which will determine
who will be the next bishop
really following what you find in uh in
scripture so
in that sense then it becomes a
breakdown of reason in the other way
it's like
an opening up for the possibility that
there are
some forms of causality which cannot be
contained in a higher way
like there could be direct influences of
heaven down onto the world without
even following the normal levels of
causality
and so that's how i understand the
meaning
of luck and so
it's hard sometimes to tell the
difference at least sometimes in your
life right
you know you can meet you can meet
really bad people that have good luck
um sometimes and so
it still tells you about reality just
sometimes you're not sure which way it's
going all right so nelson justin evan
says i am becoming a high school teacher
at a public school
i aim to guide my students away from the
modern neolis materials worldview
by exploring its shortcomings through
secular fiction
eg hedonism in the brain world illusion
of subjectivity
subjective morality and crime and
punishment what do you think would be
the most valuable themes ideas for young
people to mull over
i'd like our class discussions to plant
a seed which may grow into a full faith
of
in christ later in their lives
i mean i think it first of all it
depends your high school students
because seriously are you really going
to have your high school students read
crime and punishment because man
that's some intense stuff it's also very
long
and so maybe i mean if you have great
students that would be awesome that they
could read
crime and punishment um brave new world
is a i think it's like a standard thing
that people
that you have high school students read
it's definitely i think
i think reading 1984 in brave new world
is a really important
thing to do right now in our situation
um and so definitely i would say
it's probably a good idea to uh to have
them read that
i think
i mean i think that
i think that young people need to
understand
hierarchy just like everybody else
that's the thing that nobody
understands you know and it's also kind
of the solution to all the problems
which are
not all the problem but it's a solution
to a lot of the problems that we're
facing
which is that because we we hold on to
this equality thing
then we we if everything is either in or
out and if it's in then it's equal and
if it's out then it's out
so we can't have this normal idea of a
natural
kind of hierarchy of things where some
things exist on the margins and
are kind of weird and are kind of
off-key but they're there and we don't
talk about them too much we just kind of
leave them there
and then we nonetheless try to focus on
the virtues on something which unites us
something which holds us together um and
so i think that that's something that
people
that young people need to to understand
and it it will
it will probably help them with their
suffering you know
because this is one of the things that
is making people suffer is that
is that people have desires and then
because
even in their own life they think that
everything
is equal then they have a desire and
they immediately identify with that
desire
and then they're trapped uh
and so but if you understand even
yourself as a hierarchy then you know
that you can have
crazy thoughts and you can have crazy
desires and you can just kind of let
them flow through and just
move on right and you don't have to
latch on to them and
see them as identically important to
your other aims to your other desires to
your higher
uh vision so for sure that's what i
think
people young people need to understand
but man
good luck that's tough because it's
tough i have my own kids and
it's i'm seeing it happen now i
teenagers and uh
you know one of my teenagers is just
like
right in there like struggling with
those problems struggling with
all the problems of the stuff that we're
seeing you know all the school stuff
it's all there so it's everywhere
all right so m tara thomas says just
started reading your brother's book and
i must say so far on 30 pages in
it is both very deep and readable a most
disconcerting concept
the question has occurred to me is is
the symbolic of thinking contra
rationality
is it in dialogue or competition with
rationality it is not at all it is
actually
symbolic thinking is extremely rational
it is very very rat it is quite rational
but it is
rationality knowing its limit you could
say which is
the pattern of the symbolic pattern also
includes the places where rationality
breaks down and so
it's like a kind of meta rationality
where it sees rationality but it also
understands it also is able to see
its limits and in the in the entire
pattern
it's able to embody both the
the six days of work and the day of rest
you know
it doesn't just have the six days of
work it doesn't just have
the rational the rational because the
word isn't just made from rational right
they're
they're the irrational is part of the
world and so
and so i think that that's actually the
value of what we're trying to propose
is to be able to bridge the gap and help
people
find a way to kind of to keep a rational
capacity and but just have it in its
place and not we don't we don't
not to oppose it not to oppose science
or technology or
to oppose uh uh to oppose reason at all
but to also
but to understand where it is its proper
role
and also what is its proper function
like
it has to be aimed to some towards
something which is beyond rationality
because you can be very reasonable and
re and and use
all your capacity for reason to create
you know
a virus that will kill all of humanity
and you can do it you can use your
reason to do that
you can use your reason to do all kinds
of things and so we're
also trying to point to people that the
the purpose towards which rationality is
is aimed is is super irrational it can't
be rational
um it cannot so
all right so kathy tubern asked can you
discuss the symbolism matthew 10 34
jesus not
jesus did not come to bring peace but a
sword thank you
um and so this is really where you have
to understand
christ in his totality and this is this
is something which
really is very difficult to do i would
say it's almost impossible to do
it's also impossible to see christ in
his totality because he
is in a way a he is in a way the place
where all reality
comes from right he joins everything
together in him he
he joins all the all the extremes into
himself
and so that is one of the extremes and
so you know there are other places where
he says i am your peace right i am
here that he is the one who brings peace
you know that that he's bringing a world
where the sheep and the lion will lay
together all these
types of images are there in terms of
christ as well but there's also a way in
which
the in which he is a sword he is a
divider
um and so a really simple way to
understand it is that's what the logos
does
the logos both unites and divides
and so you can see him from the side of
uniting and you can see him from the
side of dividing
and sometimes you feel the dividing and
sometimes you feel the uniting right
sometimes you you get cleaved right
sometimes christ will cleave you
and then sometimes christ will gather
you together
and those two things are important
that's how reality exists reality is a
balancing or
coming together of separation and union
you know if you look at
the story in the beginning that's what
god is always doing
he's separating heaven and he's
separating the
the waters then he's separating earth
from
from uh the waters then he you know it's
like he
he's constantly separating things into
their
into their uh species and so it's like
separating and bringing together that's
how that's how the logos
functions um but like i said you can
also just
have the image of christ who who
who puts the goats on one side and the
sheep on the other right he puts those
that will be separated
and those that will be gathered together
um but that's really how the logos work
so
okay
all right so so from mikael do you think
christianity can be compatible with some
kind of republicanism
you often present the hierarchy of a
feudal kingdom as the best pattern of
society
yet there is an alternative pattern a
council gathered around god or the
knights
of the round table what concerns me in
mixing a government pattern with
religion
is that in the 18th 19th century russia
the orthodoxy was used as a tool for
despotism
imperialism and chauvinism um that's for
sure
uh and so you can understand
you can i think that you would you can
understand a kind of republicanism
that would have a tendency towards unity
you could say
um and so i think that like the orthodox
shirts that's how it's always been
structured
it's like it's a council of elders with
one elder that is recognized as being
kind of the first among equals right
so there is a hierarchy um
but that hierarchy is tends to want to
express itself as a gathering together
of the of the elders and like you said
the round table is a perfect example of
that where
let's say king arthur is
king arthur is the king he's the head
he's the authority
but because the union with his knights
is so close
then the he doesn't have to
he doesn't have to impose himself and so
this this um
hierarchy be looks more like a communion
than it does
a strict hierarchy in a kind of military
sense um
and so
for sure like as soon like let's say
this way as soon
as the government or the the
temporal power as soon as it subjugates
the spiritual authority
and tries to make it just a tool of
itself
then it's over it's over
it's gonna fall it's gonna it's it's
just a question of time before it falls
because it's the wrong it's the wrong
order
of of uh it's the wrong order in the
hierarchy
right and so moses is above david right
moses uh the the the prophet
the prophet is above david or the
prophet comes and the prophet tells the
king
what he did wrong and the king has to
repent or else god is gonna smite him
right the the prophet and so you see
that in this in the in the example of
king saul it's like
king saul sins and the prophet names
another king
and so the the prophet is the one who
names the king
that's the proper hierarchy but the
prophet also doesn't have weapons the
prophet doesn't it doesn't have an army
the prophet isn't
a power in that sense right he has
authority he has
influence but he doesn't have he doesn't
have the means
and so that's the relationship between
spiritual authority and temporal power
that's the normal relationship so when
peter the first
subjugated the church and made it a tool
of the state then he was just
the guillotine was down the line like
there was no way around it it was just a
question of time before before the
guillotine came to chop in
right so that's how i see it um
the only people who seem to get out of
this are the english for some reason how
is it that the english do it i don't
know
they're able to kind of find these weird
balances i don't know what's going on
with the english
all right i think i'm done
with do i have all the comments here
yeah i think i've got all the comments
for that
i'm going to go into patreon
so patreon i have a lot there's a lot of
questions patreon i think like 30
something guys thank you by the way i'm
really happy because i'm noticing people
are making an effort to not write overly
long questions
and i think just for the people watching
and people listening i think that that's
useful because
sometimes when there's so much
elaboration in the question it's uh
it's hard to uh to have all these
questions lined up so thanks people
all right so garrett witner asked the
saying spread abroad
brought among the brethren that this
disciple was not to die
jesus did not say to him that he was not
to die
peter but if it is my will that he
remain until i come
what is that to you john 21 23
so what does this mean for john and in
what way is it significant to the
biblical pattern
is john akin to the so why did he why oh
yeah okay so he says to peter that this
disciple will not die yeah
jonathan to the remnant of the church
who will not fall away in the end
times it's a very myst it's a very
mysterious
mysterious verse and it's a very
mysterious verse
uh
so a way to say it or this is the way
this is the way that i would say it and
i'm not going to elaborate too much but
this is the way that i would say it
is what christ is suggesting
is that the one who lies on the breast
of
of the messiah the one who is on his
heart the one who was close to his heart
will not if it is his will
he will remain until i come it's it's
similar
to when christ asks you know will i find
faith in the world
when when when the son of man returns
will he find faith in the world
it's similar to that but it's even more
pointed it's like
the one who remains close to the heart
of of christ is
is the one who holds the world together
with christ the one who
participates in actually holding reality
together by
embodying by being you know by
theosis by being in the heart of christ
or close to the heart of christ
and so i think that that's what christ
is talking about but i might be wrong
it's a very very mysterious verse now
it's i think he's giving us hope
that there that that there will still be
saints until the end
um and there kind of has to be in a way
or else the world will
will fall apart but it's weird because
it's like okay so if the world is
falling apart it means that
there are less saints and so how many
like are there you know is there just
gonna be one like noah
you know like in the like in the just
before the flood where there's just one
left
and uh and then that's why the world
doesn't get destroyed i don't know i
hope not
okay so julius
bars deities sorry if i mispronounce
your name julius
says hey jonathan hope all is well my
question is
if by stressing the equilibrium between
the bottom up and top down constitution
of reality one doesn't end up
with a pantheistic system
would you agree for the primacy of
spirit and if so then how
on a smaller scale what is an angel of
london if london were to burn
thanks a lot and all the best so yes for
sure there's a primacy of spirit right
right so meaning comes from above right
the voice of god comes from above
the breath of god comes from above there
is definitely a primacy
the world is held together by the logoe
right and so
there is in order for the world to exist
there is an
anchor like a heavenly anchor you could
say that's
that's so there is that's why it's a
hierarchy right it's getting close to
that
while staying in the world getting close
to that
higher place right the highest it can go
let's say
it's like the the higher that the
highest the chair can go
before it i don't know like if it
becomes disembodied or whatever that it
remains
in body but it's the closest to what
it's supposed to be right that's the
that's kind of the aim or that's the
point so yes you're right
so what is an angel of london if
london's were to burn well it's still
the angel of london
it's it's like uh there is a manner in
which things exist
in their totality uh in all eternity
right there is a way in which tempo
temporal reality
is not total and so the fact that things
in the world exist and cease to exist
are that
bodies that communion that that the
bound the bonds of love
that create higher that manifest higher
identities the fact that these
come and go in time doesn't mean that
there isn't an eternal reality to that
communion of love
um and so that's the angel of london is
the prince of
the principle of of london and he and
the angel of london exists
in all eternity in the mind of god and
and even if london were to burn and will
burn everything comes and goes
that that doesn't mean that there's that
that being
doesn't have an ontological reality in
the totality of everything
that's the best way i can explain it i
guess
all right so erling romer asked you
frequently make reference to the new
platonic school of philosophy
without mentioning any concrete names or
philosophical works
having recently been blown away by
sending the aeneids by platinus
whose doctrine of three hypostasis in
particular so strikingly congruent with
christian teaching
i wonder if you could elaborate on your
views on the merits and shortfalls of
plutonius or any other neoplatonist
i get that the new places don't nearly
ha don't have nearly as fleshed out as
story as christianity but
do you also perceive any major flaws in
the bare bones account of the hierarchy
of being
and so i'm not an expert on platinus but
i think that the way that i
see it is that
the way that i see it is that
christianity it's it's almost there in
your question it's like christianity
embodied what for the neoplatonus was
almost like an abstract science but an
abstract science doesn't
the world doesn't work that way right
it's the hierarchy of
beings they they are beings they
they they're modes of being that embody
themselves in the world
and so ultimately this ends up have
has ends up having to look like an
actual hierarchy of beings
right and so it's not you can't just
have the philosopher
uh sitting you know meditating on the
mysteries of the cosmos
you need bishops and priests and
sacraments and you need people to
congregate and to worship and you need
all these things
which which embody the this this
this metaphysical reality in the world
and so and so you could say that that
ultimately is what christ does and he
creates this anchor
uh into by which the
let's say the best aspect of the
neoplatonus can now
really be lived and embodied and not
just be a kind of
a philosophical um just a philosophical
meditation
and so i to be honest i do not know
how close or far the the the three
you know divine hypostases are in
platinus compared to christianity
and i would probably be better if i
didn't adventure myself there
because i would certainly put my foot in
my mouth and then
i there would be someone on the internet
to come after me and tell me
that i'm wrong and so all i think about
the new plateness is quite simple is
that
whatever is good about them i think we
can use it and we can
we can use it in the church and like
i've told you i've said this before like
it is it is not rare to find in churches
in the mediterranean to find the
neoplatonist the plaintiffs and the new
plaintiffs represented
in the narthex of the church and so
plato aristotle uh platinus
and these different thinkers uh would be
represented in the northeast of the
church as
people who came close you know and and
we're able to to imbibe some
truth but maybe we're missing the body
right we're missing this
incarnational aspect so that's what i
think
about them
all right so jonathan morgan asked i've
been thinking
on the of the memes of incel chad and
stacey and notice that there was a
parallel
to the story of hephaesis net
humiliating
zeus and aphrodite is this a spurious
connection to make
and are the technically skilled but
socially inept nerds of today related
to the disfigured god of smithing yeah
i think they are um
i think they are uh i mean
these are just patterns of being right
that you can understand it
like uh it's almost it's almost like the
joke of the guy with the big car
right it's it's it's the joke of the
need to compensate
because you lack something and so
you know the idea that that someone who
is socially
maladjusted or or not good looking or
not good with the ladies
would throw himself into a way to prove
his superiority in other manners uh in
kind of these external ways in these
technical ways you could say
i think it is something that is not
surprising at all
um but i you know it doesn't doesn't
mean that everybody likes technology
necessarily has that problem but
i think this to notice it as a pattern
the idea of the nerd
who's super good in technology but is
difficult has difficulty talking to
girls i think is a
i think it's a it's really a pattern
that exists it's hard to
it's hard to avoid it
all right so richard rowland asks what
is the symbolism of meteors
and especially things forged from them
you've talked a lot about the symbolism
of the forge
and of drawing up ore from beneath to
make a tool what about when it's done
with a fallen star
i sense is there something demonic about
this and this is how token handles it in
the similarity
so i don't know about how token handles
it but i would say that for sure it
would be important
that is for certain so we we have to
understand that that's what's in the
kebab
right that's in the in the the
the big black square in mecca there's a
there's a there's a stone from heaven
right that's there
and so uh i think that ancient people
would have definitely
seen these these stones that come from
heaven
as being extremely important and so
like you said the problem is asking
yourself
did it and this is actually a big this
is actually a question like this is
this is a real uh this is a real puzzle
for you richard
or people is that what is the difference
between
an angel that descends to to reveal
the will of god and an angel that
descends
to reveal to humans some secret
that they're not supposed to know like
what's the difference between the two
what's the difference between the
nephilim or the watchers
and you'd say uh the the uh
and the vision of that moses receives on
how to build the tabernacle for example
and so it's like what's the difference
between those two
and i think that that it's it's a it is
definitely as it probably is a tricky
it's it's tricky to to really
to get that i mean i think i think i
know i think i know what it is
um but i'm not sure in terms of meteors
how that could
so maybe you could say something like if
the meteor
falls to earth and let's say you use the
stone of the meteor to like make an
altar let's say uh or a throne
uh that would be something but to if you
use it to make a weapon
then maybe that's the problem in terms
of symbolism maybe it's that but i don't
know
enough stories of these these fallen uh
these fallen uh
these fallen stones so
all right so
so chase and lindsay asked hey jonathan
i have a potentially silly sounding
question so please bear with me
in the instance that man came into
contact with something like an
extraterrestrial group of
people
the proper way the proper way to act be
to treat them as the foreigner
or in a christian context as the gentile
in relation to the jew by terrestrial i
do mean flesh and blood biological
beings like man and not higher
principalities like angels
and demons i understand this is a really
silly question considering
the real possibility that there be
nothing like man spread across the
heavens
but i'm curious for a serious answer
since i have been wanting to portray
this kind of event in a story
i have been working on for over a decade
i'm curious what the proper way to deal
with such an encounter is in the context
of christianity
would there be a proper way to trade
with these beings or have relationships
and marriages with them or
without creating giants or monsters dude
you're asking questions
would it be a worthwhile effort to
potentially invite such people into
christ
or would the risk of inviting foreign
gods be too great
or we would just treat them as
dog-headed men and leave them alone
thank you for any insight into this
silly question well it's not a silly
question
in the sense that it's important to
understand it because it's floating
around it's you know people
are it's floating around in the
narrative sphere of our world
and so i think that it's important to
understand let's say the way that the
extraterrestrials are portrayed
in narrative and that has to do with the
way in which they would appear to us
you know if this something like that
would happen and so
the way they are portrayed in narrative
it can give you a glimpse
as to what they are and the way they are
portrayed in narrative
is something like really is something
like this
this the kind of uh infinite stranger
the the infinite foreigner
and so they are either represented
as gods you know
as these angelic beings that are coming
to bring us light and to bring us
knowledge into
and to save us from ourselves or they
are represented as
as man-eating crazy invaders
uh from outer space who you know who
probe you in
places and they probe you from behind
right
all of that stuff all that symbolism has
to do with the
this the foreigner that comes right and
so this the
the idea of if you don't understand that
there's a relationship for example
between the alien abductions where
people get probe from behind
and the the situation in the city of
sodom
with with the angels and lot where it's
like a weird reverse thing
but that relationship that there's
something to do with that kind of
relationship
and and the the the stranger because
it's a non-productive
relationship right uh the extreme
stranger has a non-productive
relationship with us
and so that's how you would that's how
you have to see it
one thing i can tell you very simply and
it probably wouldn't be a surprise is
that
if that happens that's just that's it
that's the end of our world like
our world's going to end if there is if
that happens our world's gonna end
and uh it doesn't mean good or like it
just means that that's what's gonna
happen
uh and so it's like apocalypto is
actually a great movie to understand
that
it's like if you have an encounter with
something which is so
far removed from you that you have no
way
no frame no way to frame it in any way
uh it's gonna end your world uh and so
that's it sorry it's like
that's that that's it um and there's and
there's a reason why it's portrayed like
that in narrative is because
people intuitively understand that
it's gonna end your world and it might
that might have positive and negative
aspects but
that's definitely what's going to happen
um
so duratia asks hi jonathan i attend
mass in the catholic church and last
sunday
the mass readings were about king cyrus
a reading from ephesians about mercy
the gospel reading was one with
nicodemus
with the famous john 3 16 line i
look i took it as a symbolism happens
moment
as i was thinking for a while now if one
of the key problems jordan peterson's
relationship with god
is his lack of belief in god's mercy in
the absolution of sins
i would like to hear uh your thoughts
thank you
i mean i think i think you're right
i think you're right in the sense that
that if you listen to how jordan was
portrays like what it means to believe
in god it usually
means a conviction of your sin like
that's what he's saying basically
he's saying that it's too heavy right
it's too heavy
um whereas god in christ
gives us this possibility of entering
into
his grace it doesn't mean of course in
orthodoxy it doesn't mean that you also
don't have to take up your cross you
don't have to
to to um
to do to take on the weight of that but
there's also a way in which
we are also relieved from that weight
through through
through through forgiveness and so
maybe maybe
all right so jeff dunlop asked it seems
like feminist with their newfound
intolerance for sexually immoral men
are actually helping bring back monogamy
yeah i thought that
but won't monogamy destroy feminism
aren't they doing this
are they doing this intentionally
there's not a lot of stuff in that world
that's happening intentionally it's like
it's it's like the war of passions you
know and
and and people don't realize all the
like people don't realize all the all
the the the
let's say the the
the implicit the the implicit uh
or not implicit but let's say the side
effects of what they're doing and so
i think we're seeing a lot of that kind
of stuff that we're seeing a lot of
a way to see it is like the idea is that
the world does lay itself out in a
certain way it has a certain hierarchy
it has a certain
natural way in which it kind of lays
itself out and you can push it like you
can go against it especially when you
get to the end
of a system or the end of a world or the
end of something and so you can
push against it but at some point it
kind of snaps back and
sometimes it's funny to watch like
you're seeing that in the very
mechanisms
of trying to break it it ends up kind of
turning on itself and then bringing it
back
you know um
you know and so yeah
there are more there are more there are
more like more of these going on like
the whole question of transgenderism is
part of this where it's like
the the transgender question is is is
actually
bringing back both kind of
is is is putting back on the table um
traditional masculinity and and
traditional femininity
in in almost like an extreme way even
and so it's actually a very strange
thing it's a
it it's a it's a strange phenomenon when
things get so weird and loopy
that all of a sudden these upside downs
start to flip on each other
and they then these the the
you can kind of pierce you can kind of
see normality representing itself
uh in the distance and i think that's
what you're seeing with this idea that
that there's something about the new
like
let's say that there's something in
feminism which is almost like a
puritanism like
a kind of uh desire for chaste uh
you know for chastity and and not
objectifying
women and not over sexualizing women all
of these things
are there in that narrative so it's a
it's an interesting
strange interesting thing
all right so mika mueller asked could
you explain more the pattern of
or of ideas or bar pattern of ideas or
barbarians descending from the north
i live in redding and i've been curious
how that pattern has manifested through
saint herman i understand that truth
works
top down is that connected to geography
um and so the north has like a double
symbolism like if you read matthew's
book you'll see that it has a double
symbolism
on the one hand it has a an aspect of it
which is light
um you know and that's manifest itself
like in terms of the snow caps right you
see
the snow that's out in the north but
there's also an aspect of the north
which is
dark in the sense that it's the place
where the sun doesn't go
you know the sun doesn't go to the north
and so
a good way to understand the north has
to do with like
extremes that's the way that i
understand the north and so the
barbarians
that descend from the north represent
kind of unleashed extremes
and um and so they they
they come down and then they pillage and
they take
but it's but it's also there's something
about that which is almost like birds
coming down from heaven right these
rapacious birds that
come down from heaven and kind of take
things
so that's kind of how i can i see the
barbarians coming from the north
but then there's also the possibility
like if so if the barbarians find a nest
if you're able to give them a nest let's
say then
then they end up settling and they end
up they end up
ruling and so this is something which in
history you'll see
happens it happens non-stop if you if
you pay attention
right that the you know the the
northerners descend from the north and
they
they at first they pillage and they they
take and they take and they destroy
they cut heads off and they rape and
they do all the stuff and then
finally someone gives them land in
france let's say
or or or someone asks them to settle
um in russia let's say and or
let's say you know they come down north
and then they end up
settling in china let's say and so then
but when that happens they become the
rulers and so
they become the aristocracy of the you
know they become the norman kings they
become the
the kings of sicily the kings of
northern italy
the kings of uh of england but also the
kings of novgorod the kings of
moscow and they become the new emperors
of china
and then they go down all the way down
and they end up becoming
the you know the emperors in india for
goodness sake and so
it's like that's how it happened but the
thing is that
they these these barbarians that come
down from the north
they don't have body it's like they need
body and so
they actually end up taking the body of
whatever it is that they encounter
it's interesting right and so it's not
like let's say the romans
it's like the romans when they invade
coming from
coming from where they are like let's
say more south we're not totally south
but let's say more south
they kind of they kind of invade and
then they they straight
interestingly enough like they they they
kind of impose their structure
everywhere
whereas when the barbarians come down
from the north
they bring a kind of a kind of breath
but then they become roman and then they
become they
they join with they become russians they
become they join with the slavs or
they basically become chinese or they
become indian
and so that's the fascinating thing
about these these barbarians that come
from the north
at least that's how that's how i
understand them
all right so lucas fernbach says is
there a kind of encyclopedia of symbols
and they're meeting
maybe that would be a nice project for
the community or would
or you could write one i would totally
pay for it so thanks lucas
but i'm really not interested in in
encyclopedias of symbols
and uh i find them very uninteresting i
don't think i own one i don't think i
own
encyclopedia symbols i always find when
i read those encyclopedias that they
that they are very arbitrary and uh
and so so i'd rather understand it
in terms of systems rather than isolate
symbols
and then try to show what they mean
because symbols don't mean
anything in themselves they always mean
something in relationship to other
elements
so for example the same object can mean
something completely different
depending on what its place is in an
image or in an area in a story
it has most to do mostly to do with this
kind of
structure pattern which shows itself and
embodies itself in different images so
that's how i see it and so that's
probably why i've never been interested
in that kind of uh
uh that kind of stuff so nina morris
asks do you think you have become a holy
fool
i don't think that i'm i'm surprised
that you say that um
i really don't think that i that i have
that
that characteristic i might have a
little bit of it
enough to understand it maybe but i
don't think i'm a holy fool
uh so anders ralstad asks hi jonathan
how does the gospels point to christ
filling
the hierarchy of being i get that the
story portrays him as uniting a lot of
opposites
but how does he fill all in all i also
get that the logos is what holds
everything together
but i do not grasp how christ showed
this as he did not explicitly incarnate
or manifest every mode of being so
you have to understand in terms of uh of
narrative
first of all a good way to understand is
to understand how
it's about categories of being and so
and so some categories are contained in
other categories so it's not like
this explicit manifestation of every
single possible category but it's rather
that for example if christ
manifests something like a king then
this whole image of the of the ruler
is embedded in that aspect let's say
if he manifests something like the one
who is cast away
right and so he's crucified outside the
city
then in manifesting that which is cast
away he takes upon himself
all the imagery of the stranger of the
foreigner
of the criminal of all of the imagery of
that which is on
the outside so it's not like he has to
necessarily embody
every aspect of humanity but like i said
because of this fractal pattern
then as his narrative shows him
filling up certain spaces of being let's
say you can by analogy notice that okay
but these other spaces fit in that one
right
and so and so like i said the idea that
he is
out he is crucified outside the city has
a huge
amount of importance okay but ultimately
if you want to see the place where
where uh he fills the the hierarchy it's
it's in the crucifixion that's
really the place where he feels it the
most where
and it it happens in a kind of
simultaneity
that is really hard to think about so
you know i've talked about this before
where
for example he has a title the title
which is put above him his name is
written above his head
his his his role his title as king of
the jews
um but it's but in that title is both
the opposite the irony because it's not
it's supposed to mock him
right it's supposed to actually
represent the opposite of what is said
on
the title but then it also is
manifesting
the fact that he's the king of the jews
at the same time
and so by actually manifesting opposites
in simultaneity that is one of the ways
that christ
is manifesting everything at the same
time it's really rather astounding
that this can happen in the story so uh
and then in
in the in the on the cross when he dies
so christ i've said this before also
that it said that he went down
and preached to the souls which were
imprisoned right
so he goes down into shale he goes down
into death
but then when he dies he also says right
he says to the to the thief think about
that right he says to the thief to the
sinner
he says today you will be with me in
paradise
so even in that little bit of story
he takes the sinner the one who's
condemned to death who
is condemned is the one who's supposed
to go
down into the prisons and he says it's
almost like he's saying
i am going down with you in the prison
but don't worry
i'm bringing you way all the way back up
into the highest place
and it's all gonna happen in this weird
simultaneous and this weird
simultaneity so he goes down into the
prison and then he rips the veil of the
temple
out all happening at the same time right
um
and so those are just little aspects but
i mean it's like my goodness nonstop
every every story of christ has that
insane like insane amount of of
uh of opposites like maybe one day i
should just go through the gospels and
just kind of
take every single thing that christ does
and just show you just how much
almost everything he does has this kind
of just
insane amount of opposites kind of
coming together and this simultaneity of
extremes uh happening in him
um so yeah it's pretty it's pretty
astounding
hopefully that answers a little bit your
question but i can't i can't
do i can't give you every example here
that's for sure
all right so jeremy morgan uh asked
i was talking to an old country
veterinarian who told stories about how
they used to use maggots to treat
wounds in cattle apparently they are
good at cleaning the wound and removing
dead bits yeah
it sounds like a creature associated
with death and corruption being used to
consume death and corruption
so what would be considered an inversion
is that the symbolic structure of
medicine in general or vaccine in
particular
is there a better way to interpret that
story no i think your interpretation
is perfect in terms of the idea of using
death
against death the idea of using an
aspect of death to
to deal with another aspect of death um
and so like what would be
what so an inversion of that
is not that it's not that complicated
like an inversion of that would be
that it's seen right it's seen that
the cow is there to
to either feed the the maggots
right uh that that the cow the existence
of the cow is more
the existence of the maggots is more
important than the cow let's say
and that the purpose of the whole
situation
is so that the maggots can eat the
the let's say the disease and and live
right and so that would be an inversion
and so
so think about that as you wish and find
your examples in reality of
that kind of that kind of pattern
playing itself out
let's say all right so kevin patterson
says given that
intelligence and intellect dominate our
competence hierarchies what is the
proper place
for these faculties in the spiritual
hierarchy
i guess is that it's related to the
bottom of reality under the mountain
where
metal or g started so it's that that
really depends what you mean
see the word in intellect and
intelligence is
is a very is a word that has lost its
meaning
um so the word intellect or intelligence
is definitely a word that is used
by christian mystics all the time
that's what the word noose means and so
in greek we have this idea of the
intellect the noose
and the noose is this the pure spiritual
faculty
you could say it is the faculty
the person has to intuit reality
directly
and it can lead let's say if purified
then this intellect is capable of seeing
the god seeing the divine the the the
uncreated light right the glory of god
um
and so that is really what the intellect
ultimately that is what the intellect
means in the christian tradition
now what you probably mean by
intellect is something like reason or
something like
reasoning faculties and so reasoning
faculties is not the same as
the intellect in the in the the
spiritual sense
the intellect is that which grasps
directly it doesn't deliberate
right then lower down in terms of reason
that's where there's deliberation
that's where that's where there's a for
and against that's where there's
a action reaction that's where there's
example counter example
all of these things happen in the world
of in the world
of reason and in the world of reason is
the one that is used to make things
to apply the insights down into the
world
it's useful but it's not the same as
the as the intellect and so
the one of the ways let's say in terms
of spiritual practice which which might
surprise people
is that one of the ways to reach the
intellect is actually to
to strip the reasonable part
is to snit is to strip uh
not to say that it's bad but the because
we rely so much on reason
and on deliberation and on thinking and
on all of this stuff
uh there is an aspect of spiritual
practice which is
to strip that away right so that you can
attain
the direct the direct intuition they can
you can you can see god uh
and so and so that's why for example
like
in if you read the the fathers if you
read the the hesicastic fathers
right you have to ignore your thoughts
you have to not
be attached to your thoughts as you're
praying you have to let the thoughts
the logies moy like these little
thoughts you just have to let them flow
through and not
not grab onto them um and there are all
these different practices which are
meant to
bring you in that trans-rational like a
meta-rational
beyond the rational sphere and like i
said it doesn't mean that rationality is
bad but that
because it's so powerful it can be an
obstacle if you're not careful and you
can get attached to it and think that
that's all you are
um so yeah so hopefully that helps you
so so alfonteo says hijath and i'm from
france and i'd like to subtitle some of
your videos in french to make them more
accessible
a few months ago it was possible to do
directly on youtube but the
functionality is no longer accessible
to the ordinary viewer nevertheless i
believe that it is possible to do it one
way or another
if you're interested in me doing so so
so i i really appreciate it uh
too if you want to do that that's fine
but i think you have to learn how to do
it because like you said you can't do it
directly
what you would have to do is you would
have to i don't know how it worked but
you would have to translate the video
using a subtitle file and then you would
have to send me the file
completely done with all that all the
the subtitles and the timestamps in it
so i don't know how it works
but if you have that if you send me that
then then i can go into the video
and i can apply the subtitle i can
upload the subtitle file
and then it'll work so if you want to do
that i would be extremely grateful
but but uh but i don't know how it works
i just know
that that that right now that's the only
way to do it
all right so eb says following on from
the perspective on breathing that you
explained in your video on the jesus
prayer
what if any connection is there to the
fact that singing or speaking aloud
occurs
during an out breath should we connect
these acts with dying sleeping sunset et
cetera
so no you i you shouldn't you shouldn't
uh
you're close in the sense that you're
right that there's a meaning
but you shouldn't see it with dying or
sleeping you should
see it as an externalization and so
there's a manner in which
externalization
is a form of dying in the sense that
it's an emptying
right but there's also a manner
in which externalization is expression
right it is manifestation you could say
and so so you're right that you can say
that
expiring or blowing is a form of
manifesting right and so
it's like of of emptying yourself out
into
the world not just in a negative way
right so christ when christ
blows on his disciples uh he is it's
like he's extending himself onto them
right
so that's the same with when you speak
when you when you speak to somebody
you're
you're extending your intelligence into
the person in front of you
and if we and so and if we do it
together
right so if we sing together and we sing
the same thing
and we sing towards god then we become
the same body you see how that works
it's like
because your extension is joining with
the extensions of the other
and is directed towards god then we act
together
right we act with one mind we act with
one voice
and so so it's not necessarily it
doesn't necessarily have to be
understood as as as uh there's a
relationship right
between externalization and and and
dying and sleeping and all of this but
in this case you you have to see it more
in terms of the
of the positive aspect of the body right
um
the body as being the externalization of
your
of your will or of yourself or of your
being
i feel like when i answer with all these
those words i'm probably confusing
people
hopefully not hopefully there are enough
questions that i answer very simply
and then a few questions that i answer
in a way that is complicated but i don't
do it on purpose i promise you
all right so dom palermo asked you
mentioned potential discussion
with the bible project guy the question
of how the pattern of scripture is the
pattern of everything supposing you are
primarily referring to the pattern
of the incarnation as seen as the
emergence of the chair and the parable
of the sower and the pattern of the
flood death space
okay am i correct in presuming the main
difficulty for people in drawing
analogies with everyday things
is that the power of sacrifice and
resurrection of christ of divine logos
therefore
informs the essential spark foundational
to the emergence
of missiles and porn
and idolatry if so what say you have
this problem
is this a question of toying the line of
facts that we are not yet prepared to
take in
so the power of sacrifice and
resurrection of christ the divine
logos therefore informs the essential
spark
foundational to the emergence of
missiles and porn and idolatry
um okay i understand i kind of
understand what you mean i
kind of understand what you mean um
so the way to i think the the problem is
that
this is one of the reasons why i talk
about monsters all the time right i talk
about monsters all the time because
that's where we are
and so it's very difficult for us to
understand
the pattern of the top of the mountain
but it's not difficult for us to
understand the pattern of the bottom of
the mountain
right it's not difficult for us to
understand the golden calf it's not
difficult for us to understand
you know uh all the stuff that happens
at the at the in the lower sphere the
thorns the garments of skin
the the the you know all of this stuff
is not difficult for us to understand
because that's what we deal with
so that's one of the reasons why i
actually um
i actually talk about those things and
so for example
let's say helping people understand
the place of missiles and porn and
idolatry
could be a way to help them see that
this is a pattern right
and hopefully help them see that there's
a higher aspect to this pattern right
that's just
that dark stuff it actually points to
something more
um um but maybe that's
that's i don't know like i don't i don't
totally understand why
i my sense of
a lot of the people who kind of see
these patterns haven't yet or
it's gonna happen it's just a question
of time i think haven't yet
intuited that these are really the
pattern of our
of our experience um
[Music]
but uh but yeah um and so
but if you want to understand like i i'm
tempted to go there
this is something that will seem really
weird to people but
there is an aspect of things like what
you said
let's say there is an aspect of the the
pornification of the world in general
right not just pornography proper but
let's say
the pornification of the world which is
what christ told us he was going to do
like or what christ told us what was
going to happen
right he the con one of the consequences
of
the logos spreading out into the world
imagine like the light spreading out
into the world think of it that way
so it's like the light is filling up the
world and so
the light filling up the world is
revealing the world
and one of the things it does is it
reveals all the
dark stuff it's two right it reveals the
mysteries we
we have access to the mysteries of
theosis we have access to
to to these mysteries which have been
hidden from the beginning of time
but we but it's also at the same time
exposing
all the scandals all the corruption all
the
all the the and christ said that that's
what was gonna do right that
right one of the things christ has come
to expose
the scandals and so so now that we see
it happening and now that
every perversion every every dark
corner of the human psyche is exposed
for all to see
of course we don't like that we don't
we're not saying it's good
you know christ said scandal must happen
but woe you know to those by whom it
happens
um but it's still christ acting in the
world
you know it's it's still happening right
the story of christianity is still
happening even if
we're seeing the scandal of it right
we're seeing how the revelation of the
world
is now uh is now showing us the monsters
right the monsters
are the ones we see so we just have to
remember
like just remember god uh
in this moment and you know and and and
hope that what christ said to
to peter about about john how he will
you know if it's his will that he
remains you know until the end
and we hope that that's what's going to
happen
all right so nom nom jonathan thank you
for all your recent videos
your discussion with jbp was
particularly touching and insightful
albeit hard to watch at times yeah
my question is is there a symbolic
connection between
the division cain abel jacob issa
northern southern kingdoms
right and the split between roman
catholic and orthodox
or even the ever-increasing fracturing
of denominations
throughout the centuries if one of
satan's descriptors is the scatterer and
christ gathers
is it fair to expect unification someday
well for sure i mean it is definitely
fair to expect unification someday it's
it's right there right it's the heavenly
jerusalem which descends it's an
eschatological
promise that one day there will be
unification and there will be you know
there will be the glory of god will rule
uh directly in the world and and all
nations will be
joined together if you read the
description of the
new jerusalem it's pretty amazing it
says it says that in the new jerusalem
has gathered
all the glory and honor of the nations
so it's like it's it's there in
scripture that that's
what that's the promise of the end right
um
and so yes um
i think i think we have to be able to
differentiate
let's say the system of antichrist or
the system of the beast and the heavenly
jerusalem and
and that's not that easy to do i think
it's possible but it's not that easy to
do
and hopefully that's one of the things
i'm going to be able to help people do
in these videos in the next two videos
that i'm doing as well
um but i don't really see the the
the split between roman catholic and
orthodox as
related to jacob esau and uh
kane and abel i and northern southern
kingdoms
i see it more in terms of of jews and
christians
that's for sure that that story is
related to jews and christian um
i might be able to answer another one of
a question that keeps coming back and
that nobody for some reason seems to
ever get the answer to
uh but uh the uh
the the esau or edom in uh
in scripture and in jewish tradition uh
and especially in jewish tradition is
really understood as rome
really understood as the as uh as uh as
rome
and so and so yeah all right so let's
let's continue all right so
so jason gatowald asks what is the
relationship between the apostles saint
peter and saint john
and so there seems to be like an inner
outer relationship between st peter and
saint john at least that's the way i
understand it
there seems to be this idea that saint
john is on the breast of christ
saint john is the one that christ loves
you know the one who knows the mystery
the one who talks about the unity of
christ
with his father the unity of all us in
christ that he really is the mystical
apostle i guess and that saint peter
is the one who acts he's the one who is
is in a way he is the foundation stone
but is
also uh he's also the stumbling stone
like it
he also has those two kind of weird
roles he seems to
flip between one and the other um but
he's he's on more on the outside
um he's more like the action let's say
and so but there's an interesting thing
like there's an interesting thing
uh and this is something that i know
jacob russell has been thinking about
for a long time i don't know if he's
ever gonna write that article
that he promised me or they didn't
promise me but
he suggested uh about the
the christ about uh john and peter at
the
at the tomb and how you know uh
like saint john so if you even forget
now which one it is it's horrible but
like one arrives first and then the
other one goes in
here i strip and stops and the one other
one goes in so this is the relationship
between christ and peter
has to do with the inside and the
outside um
so bradley says that he should should do
that article on john and peter
all right go for it brad all right so g
garcia says
i am having trouble conceptualizing time
it seems that you have a cyclical view
of history when i hear you talk about
technology and the ark it sounds almost
linear
as if after every death or fall there is
a rebirth and centering it sounds
like it all culminate in an end of
history type thing almost like alien
i can't help but think there's something
that separates this from a christian
eschatology
and it's right in front of my face
thanks for your time
um so i don't know i mean definitely
i think that the time is cyclical
it's just not 100 cyclical it's it's
like a
spiral you could say you know it's kind
of like that and so there definitely is
a
and there definitely is like a bigger
cycle
so there there are these cycles and it's
kind of moving towards
towards something but like it's
definitely cyclical because if you look
at
revelation the description of the holy
city
is also the garden of eden it's a return
to eden and so there is this return
but it's not just a return it's like a
it's like a
it's like a return with a crown you know
and that's
something that mature tries to bring
about in his book right this idea of
um of like space crown by time or time
crown by space
and that is like how things actually
come together is that
these there's a transcending of this
duality between time and space
but in a in this this aspect as in one
becomes it's kind of
becomes the the glory of the other is
maybe the best way to say it i don't
see how else to say it um
so so yeah so i don't know
i don't know if it's hegelian or not i
think that it's
it's uh probably not it's
probably not because it's not a it's
it's like something
say if i talk about the idea of time uh
crowned by
by space it doesn't look like just a
synthesis there's something more there's
something more happening
there um all right
all right so how many questions are left
man there's a lot of questions
all right i need to speed up a bit guys
sorry about that
i told him mr fajo when you were
speaking to dr peterson i feel like we
saw something akin to the foreign saving
the familiar
the form of the spiritual person
advising the psychologist who would
normally be the advice giver
and so this suggests to me that your
conversation had a very redemptive
function for the world in particular
for those who paid close close attention
am i off base in seeing this pattern of
ornamentation manifested here
um can you elaborate on the part of the
pattern of ornamentation i don't know if
that's what's going on
i'm not sure um definitely not
ornamentation
um
so i'm not sure i i totally agree with
the way you
frame this but i do hope that the
conversation had a redemptive function
like in the sense that i mean i've been
getting a lot of emails of people
who seem to have been kind of moved and
nudged
closer to something more and so
i thank god for that is all i can say so
hello jonathan
i don't know if this is the best place
to ask this since your content is not
madely apologetic
and i really hope no one takes offense
to my question it comes from a place of
sincerity and searching
so i'm a protestant but for the last few
years i've really felt a draw to the
orthodox church so much so
that i feel close to a point of
conversion the one thing holding me back
is the intercession of saints
i know perfectly well that it is not
idolatry but please tell me how
it is not inquiring of the dead as
deuteronomy speaks of
god is the god of the living yes but is
there further biblical support for the
practice
if anyone watching or anyone else has an
answer please tell me i don't
make it to the stream as it airs
unfortunately but i will
both watch and read the chat later
um well the answer is
the answer is is pretty straightforward
and i mean it might not be enough for
you but the answer is that
they have eternal life they're not dead
they're just not
that's really the the answer and
and so the idea is that
because they're not dead then it then it
becomes
this intercession of the saints becomes
a way to show that the body is one right
there are not
there there's only one head and one body
there are not two bodies there isn't
the body of the dead and the body of the
living there isn't
the body of those still on earth and the
body that is
you know somewhere else there's only one
body and the body
is an eschatological body right and so
you could say something like
the place from which the saints are
interceding from us
is something like the kingdom of god it
doesn't make total sense in terms of
linear
linear time but the idea that the
kingdom of god is already present with
us and that the reality of the kingdom
and the reality of the resurrection is
already has inklings in our world
is something which is totally based on
many of the things that christ has said
in terms of
you know saying the kingdom of god is
among you the you know the
the the idea that that we are
meant to be this body and this body like
i said is one
and so the idea is it's when you ask a
saint to intercede for you it's like you
when you ask your
priest to intercede for you or ask your
friend to intercede for you
it's only that having let's say
let's say you could say something like
having run the race
and having made the good fight then they
become one of those
who are considered to be the just right
and
and like it says in in the epistle of
james the prayer of the just
is efficient the prayer of the just has
power because they
embody christ in a specific aspect of
reality
and so that is also one of the reasons
why we
asked the saints to intercede for us is
that they have shown by their life by
their works by their
by their glory that they have
embodied christ you know to the extent
that that they can
and uh and so they they they help us
you know to participate in that whole
pattern of being the body of
being raised up into christ you know and
being gathered together and given
and given up to the father all of this
is this this kind of
cycle of intercessory prayers where the
saints pray for us and
we pray for each other and we we pray
for our priests and the priest prays for
us and
there's this this kind of this
web of prayer which is happening all
through the body
of christ which is part of what holds it
together
right the intercession attention
is how reality works right reality works
through attention and so
remembering the saints naming them you
know
asking of them to pray for us and then
you know praying for those that have
departed
all of this and asking for the saints to
pray for them and this whole cycle
is kind of like an entire huge a huge
web
right huge web of attention that is
holding the body together
right and that is that web of attention
that web of of love is better it's
better to say love
attention is just just because people
aren't used to using that word it's
something maybe can surprise people a
little bit to
get them to think about this but let's
say the web of love is what
also this is what will resurrect right
this is
what the resurrection is also about or
the kingdom the resurrection into the
kingdom that's what it's also about so
hopefully that makes sense bjorn
all right so vic surda asked can you
please talk about the sin of sloth
assadia i've been reading about the
seven deadly sin but this sin in
particular is very disturbing
since it seems different from the rest
yes and how can one
overcome it thank you jonathan so
yeah man
i mean the sin of zasadia that's the sin
of us
like that's our sin man that's that i
would say that if there's one sin that
that uh that represents the modern world
is the sin of assadia saint john the
damascene saint john uh
no saint john of the latter sorry saint
john of the latter says that
it is in a way kind of like it's
different from all the other sins it's
almost like all the sins
can be can be kind of contained into the
sin
of assadia so what is the sin of
asadiyah what is it
uh i can use let me explain it in a way
that that
is usual to the way i explain things so
maybe it can help you understand it if
you've been paying attention
to what i'm talking about so it's like
the sin of acidity is something like
the incapacity to pay attention it's
something like that
right and so that's why it's hard to
understand if you don't kind of
understand it that way
then then you'll struggle to understand
the descriptions of it because
it's not just laziness uh because the
sin of acidity
is also the sin of a busy body it's the
sin
so for example one of the descriptions
of the sin of asdia
is the monk in his
cell who wants to see people
who wants to go out and talk to people
so that's also the sin of acidia
and like you can imagine that someone
who
is uh sitting around and is bored
that's the sin of assadia who wants to
see change
that's the sin of assadia but also sloth
in the most in the more general sense in
the sense of
of laziness of incapacity to do the
things you need to do
um all of that is the incapacity to pay
attention
so the sin of acidity can actually
manifest itself as
being extremely busy because you can't
imagine being alone like you can't
imagine stopping
you can't imagine let's say stopping in
silence and prayer and so your
mind and your your activity moves from
one thing to the other you always need
to be distracted
right that's the sin of acidia and so
and so like i said it can manifest
itself
as this desire to be constantly
distracted so
so the sin of acedia i don't have it
here
but the sin of acidity is looking at
your phone every five minutes
that's the sin of acidia checking your
phone is the sin of acidia
every time you you can't help yourself
to check your phone
you are manifesting acidia uh
you know every time you use doom scroll
facebook you are manifesting acidia
every time you every time you
you you know you're you you're just
you're
you're bored and you're wondering what
to watch uh
or you absolutely have to watch
something or you don't know what to
watch because you don't know what to do
all of these are all acidia so it's like
the the kind of overpowering fatigue
that you get when you need to do
something
it's acidity is often called the demon
of uh of noon the noon demon the noonday
demon right
and so one of the images people have of
the of the acid the demon of acidia is
right the uh the guy in his late 40s 50s
who who uh all of a sudden you know
leads his wife buys uh you know buys a
sports car and gets a young girlfriend
that's the sin of acidia it's the
incapacity to hold attention it's like
i need to be distracted i need to change
i need a new car i need new clothes i
need
a new tv i need all of this is all
acidia so it's like
if you want to understand the sin of our
world
it's acidia and what's the solution to
it
uh you know i mean the fathers say it's
patience
which is just really difficult for us
you know stillness and patience you know
a capacity to attend
uh capacity to pray you know
because often a lot of these things are
there to stop us from praying um
so yeah so good luck with that but i'm
saying
like you noticed that the examples are
just streaming out of me
because i am a slave of assadia just
like most of you as well
and i i can see that and uh and so we
need to to develop
uh discipline in prayer and discipline
in solitude and the capacity to
to attend
all right so anjo terpstra says what is
symbolism what is the symbolism of
dividing of the garments
and casting lots for the clothing in
psalm 22.
so dividing of the garments has to do
with
the idea of losing the kingdom right and
so
the garments are divided the kingdom is
is is broken the kingdom is
is uh scattered and so you can unders
you can imagine it as anything that has
unity
that its body is is broken it's
scattered
and so this dividing of the garments
right is the is a is a form of
of death but the casting of lots of the
clothing is a little different right
and so in this case there really is this
idea of the entirety of the garment
right you see that especially in the
story of christ where it's like
the body of christ if you think of the
garment as like an extension of body
right then you have to
see how fascinating it is that christ on
the cross
his garment is cast by lots so it's like
a breakdown of meaning right it's
this i told you about luck just before
this breakdown of meaning this place
where
there isn't a a a coherence of causality
and then the body through this
through this breakdown of reason and
coherence goes
to someone and it goes to the roman one
of the roman soldiers
and and so it's like yeah that's the
story of christianity
right the the the body of christ moved
outside and and it's one like it's
one body it's not it does it's
that's the whole insistence on the the
fact that the the garment is not divided
because the church is one and it's a
mystery look it's a mystery dude
i can't i'm not gonna tell you but
that's christians have always said that
the body is one the body is not divided
and so the church is not divided the
church is one and so we look around and
we see
all these these schisms and all this
crap and so we think okay so i don't i
can't i don't know
you know and then other people will just
say that that you know the whole the
body is always one but it's just like
whatever
my denomination and so i guess that's a
way to solve that problem i don't think
it totally solves it
there's something more mysterious
happening a kind of weird union of
of opposites i don't i can't resolve it
in reason
but there seems to be this yeah it seems
that seems to be what's going on
in the history of the church is this
this problem of the dividing of the
garments but also the
the the the whole the let's say the the
garment without a scene
which is cast and ends up
being won but given to the romans right
that's all right craig holland is there
a mystery that compromises
that compromises
is it is there a mystery that
compromises get made when a sacrifice
that can embody everything
is seen as powerful to show
vulnerability and death
for this allows risks to proclaim
everlasting communion i'm afraid
when a sacrifice can embody everything
that is seen as powerful
to show vol i'm afraid i do not
understand your question craig
it seems like you've got a good question
but i don't i don't think i understand
it enough to answer i'm sorry
all right so leo asked i find jk
chesterton to be the funniest and most
imaginative thinker
i've come across are you a fan too i am
a fan of
chesterton i i haven't like uh
i haven't i'm not an expert on
chesapeake and i've read a little bit
and i've read
you know parts and and uh sections but
definitely every time i encounter
uh chesterton i always find him
surprising and witty
so christian sacra says i've heard
people like tamale and jordan peterson
struggle with the idea
of the christ event being the center of
history usually pointing as things
a thing so far away from him like the
dinosaurs or other solar system that it
could never be relevant to those things
at the same time they seem to accept the
permeating presence of hierarchy
everywhere
could you make a convincing argument
from a hierarchy of
moments or events in which christ at the
top
and present
all all thought out
it all thought out it
in which christ at the top and present
all thought out it i'm sorry i don't i
don't understand your phrasing
i think jesus tried to do this in his
mystical dance at the end of
perilandra but it's hard to translate
out of its
poetic language
okay so this is this is really
it's difficult it's difficult to explain
this to
someone let's say this type of person uh
but it has to do with what i said before
in terms of
the union of extremes
in christ and it also has to do with the
revelation
on the cross the revelation
that the lamb on the altar
is did there okay so it has to do with
the fact that
christians we now put the altar in the
holy of holies
that that there is a mystery which is
shown in
christianity which is that
all reality is based on sacrifice
and but the sacrifice that christ offers
is like
it's like all the sacrifices together
this is something by the way if you
listen
i i'm just going to keep plugging this
podcast non-stop
but if you listen to the lord of spirits
podcast
uh uh father stephen and father andrew
did one on the atonement which was
amazing
where they talk about the two extremes
of
yom kippur the two extremes of the day
of atonement
which is this this like goat going out
to the edge of the world
and then this goat used to to
sanctify the holy place right these two
extremes and and what father stephen
chose which is totally right is that
christ is both goats he's both at the
same time and so
it's hard because it's like there's so
much
there's so much ignorance um
there's so much ignorance now and and i
wonder sometimes if
it's not if it's not a function of
christ himself like if
christ also didn't blind us or blind
blind some aspect of us to the mystery
that he was revealing to us
and so we can't totally see all of it we
get these
we get these little parts of it we get
these sparks we see these
lights but we you know it's like it's
this everlasting revelation where
you constantly are like oh wait a minute
like he has all these aspects
into so i see for example like i have
some glimpse of how christ unites all
these opposites
but then i know that there are some
things i'm still missing i know for sure
and so you know so i think it's very
difficult to
to it's very difficult to um to explain
it
um you know and it's mostly what it
what's
what it's doing maybe like if you can
notice what it's doing you can notice
what
christ is doing in the world
and you can if you can understand for
example that christ contains
antichrist like even that like if you
can understand how christ
in his own story so like what others
what other character for example like so
i don't know maybe you can find one in
the story he's like
what other story is there a character
who chooses his own betrayer
and rides that story out like rides out
being betrayed
from within right and then
coming to the end of that right and so
it's like
the idea that christ prophesizes
his own demise in terms of his own death
and he chose judas but then you can see
that as a cosmic scale so you can see
that
the the decline of christianity is part
of the pattern
and i've said this many times before
it's like atheism could just come out of
christianity
they couldn't come out of anything else
like this this mass
atheism which comes and rises up and
then destroys
christianity is part of the story it's
part of the non-duality of the story
which christ is revealing
this is what makes him the center of
everything is that he also contains his
own dissolution
it's like what the heck man that story i
can't get over it
all right okay i need to keep going
because i'm never gonna end this
all right so aj says hey jonathan i hope
all is well
um i'm having a hard time understanding
the concept of the margin in respect to
theosis
would you say that sin is the margin in
terms of human behavior because if so
jesus told us to be perfect right things
like the garments of skin were revealed
to have
had a proper place in creation all along
but i don't see how this can be
true of sin i hope that makes sense so
yes well there's a difference between
sin and death
which is very important but there's also
a reality which is that christ became
sin
i'd you make sense of that one like just
make sense of that one
christ became sin too for us
um and christ turns that
into glory he turns sin he turns death
into glory and that's the role of the
margin
the margin is glory
i think i've said this several times
like if you if you listen to my talk on
on saint from the syrian uh
i explain it like even in terms of of
the word like
the garments of light in scripture
the idea of the garments of light comes
from the text which talks about the
garments of skin that's where
it originates so the garments of skin
and the garments of light are made of
the same stuff
they're not the same in the sense that
that which is glory falls into this
course
into this coarse death but then that
which is death can then be
turned back into glory so you think of
it of like
your extensions and so it's like your
extensions
can be dead but they can also be
your light the way that you affect the
world right the way that you
that you interact with the way that you
overflow into reality
okay and so that's the secret of the
margin
the secret of the margin is that it can
be turned into glory
and so it doesn't mean that marginal
things are good in themselves all these
monsters all these
dark things all these these these
chaotic things and that's not what i'm
saying
obviously not right the garments the
skin are the garments of skin
but there is there is there is a mystery
like i said that
the crown of thorns becomes a crown of
glory
um so yeah
all right so ron wood says what is the
symbolic significance
of depicting christ's hair as long with
the language of iconography is it
possible parallel
to that of samson's hair length perhaps
it's long because
uh shorter hair length could be seen as
nakedness in a way i mean you're right
it does have to do with samson in the
sense that
christ is described as being a
nazarite like he's he's described he's
described as being a nazarene
um but i think that also
is related to being a nazarite in the
sense that
the tradition is that he was he he was
dedicated
like dedicated to god just like the
nazarites in uh
in the in scripture and so
um yeah so
no i think i said the opposite so then
so in
in the scripture the those that had made
a nazarene
vow or nazar i think nazarite and
nazarene they they would keep their hair
long and not cut their beard and so i
think that's why christ
is represented that way all right so
puerto mal
asked uh hi jonathan
i've heard you say that contrary to the
popular modern belief christians do not
have a linear view of time
is there in christianity something like
the four ages described in hinduism
do you think the idea of cycles of time
in his room are
in hinduism or applicable in any way
into a christian worldview
thank you for your work as always um
there's i think there's something of
that it's not the same
but there is definitely in scripture
like you really do see this succession
of
of falls in the old testament for sure
um
and so uh i don't know enough about
the the the you know the the cycles in
hinduism to kind of say but
the one thing that happens for sure in
christianity
is the surprise right it's the surprise
of the new jerusalem
and so so in a way it's like a it's it's
as if there's a
fall but there's a covering of the fall
every time and so
the you know the christ becomes the this
covering of this fall and he like i said
he changes the fall into something else
he
kind of changes death into glory and so
in this last image of the new jerusalem
as the finality of everything
really not doesn't just like it's not
just like the end
like the the the cycle ends and then
it's restarted
in like a seed form you could say which
is something that you
that you can imagine in terms of a
succession of cycles but it's rather
that
the cycle ends and then what comes from
above
or what comes down is a resolution of
the whole cycle
it's like a it's like a synthesis of
everything with the city on the outside
and you know on this mountain with the
city and then the tree and the rivers of
life
um you know and so
that's that's maybe the difference or i
don't know if it's a difference i don't
know enough about those cycles but
that's at least the christian vision
all right so harry fisher hi jonathan in
wrestling with christianity i find
myself constantly oscillating
between space and time where an identity
and a level
of confidence is established only to
then be thrown into question
by the remainder i'm wondering if this
has to do with the problem of
understanding with the mind versus the
heart
as the mind works in logical categories
which are necessarily exclusive
therefore i was creating a remainder
which comes back to bite i don't know i
do kind of know that the level of
certainty i'm looking
for may not exist prior to making the
commit area your question is very long
just as with marriage you don't do it
because you calculated all of the wives
in the world and determined the best one
yeah this does seems seem at
odds with a lot of christians though who
insist that their story is the best and
not just that they love it
and it's compatible with them or
whatever is that just because
the religion is a higher reality than
the wife and thus more qualitative
sorry for the confusing question i have
to admit arie i'm don't
totally confuse your understand your
question
i'm confused man who sees so much value
in joining the body but doesn't want to
do so well
doubting it all right i'm not totally
sure how to answer your question there's
a there's something in your question
about the idea of
like a qualitative jump you know in the
sense that
something isn't made of all its parts
because if you if that's how you see it
then that's
also how you end up with the like let's
say the
the problem of the remainder is is more
problematic
if you don't make that qualitative jump
but if you make the qualitative jump
which is like
right this jump up you know uh
in terms of hierarchy of being then then
maybe that can help you
um so i'm not sure if if what i'm saying
helps you it's like you said it's like
you don't you don't get married because
you compared
all the you know all the wives and then
you you've made all these calculations
then you make it's like you
you get married because you love or that
you you say
that one and so it's like that pointing
that choosing that's selecting
that's different that's this gestalt
right this
coming together um and it that has more
to do with logos or with this
capacity for things to kind of come
together and so
hopefully that helps and so it also has
to do with
there's something about the way you look
at the world too and so there's
something about how
how the the fathers will talk about how
you need to not look at other people's
sins
you need to not attend
to other people's sins and by not
attending to other people's sins
there's something about the communion
which will become more real in the sense
that
i think i've talked about this before
because a person is made of an
intermentable amount of facts and an
indefinite amount of realities that are
kind of coming together
if you attend to the good things in the
person
like if you attend to the good that that
person has the image of christ in them
rather than
all the foibles that surround it then
you are actually participating
in making that being become that
because it's it's subtle but it's like
as they interact with you and they see
in your eyes how you see them or how you
you portray them
then they're called by that they're
called by that
perception that you are having on them
there's a
there's like a there's a shaping of
reality which is happening
happening as we love each other and
we don't look at each other's foibles is
we're
moving towards we're moving towards this
image of christ in all of us
um and so so maybe that's
also about going in like i'm not saying
you have to avoid when people do
horrible things
like especially if there's if people if
there's really
evil being done but i'm talking about
the little foibles and all these things
these kind of uh
these little imperfections these
annoying things that people do and say
um so yeah hopefully that helps
okay so jl there's a reason when
discussing symbolism we're all
we are drawn to using analogies to
furniture
also cutlery and kitchenware to help us
for the point why is that
is it that furniture is art that is
mostly completely util in a world where
everything else is mantras gratuitous
or decoupled from its original use what
is the symbolism of furniture
why in almost every language other than
english the word furniture furnitures
cognate
to something like movables um
can you please tell my mom that you're
not part of the intellectual dark web
and that the intellectual dark wherever
it's run its course so i can start by
that
i am not part of the intellectual dark
web i've never said that i was part
of the intellectual dark web i never
talk about the intellectual dark web
and the only time that i've explicitly
really referenced them
is on twitter i said that i have never
considered myself part of this
this conglomeration of uh intellectuals
and
as you said it's over anyways it was
never something which was gonna hold
together
because you know it was just not it was
just not uh it was just not coherent
so so hopefully that helps well i think
the reason why we
we talk about furniture or tools is
because they're so close to us like
they're not
us but because they're caused by us
then we can see their being in a
different way than we can see things in
nature because
we can more easily see their purpose so
i think things in the world also have
purposes but
i think it's easier to it's easier when
i talk about beings that have
human purposes because you can notice
how intelligent forms reality more
easily when you talk about chairs and
tools and
cups and all these things because there
are extensions of human
intelligence into the world more more
clearly let's say
so stu gillespie cook says cats or girls
dogs are boys disgust
i'm not gonna discuss that stupid sorry
charlie longoria jonathan hope you're
well i've been struggling to fully
understand what it means that god spoke
the world into being by using
the word to create everything
as someone who is not very
intellectually sophisticated and also
infected with the materialistic
worldview how can i better understand
how the logos created the universe
i hope this makes sense thank you for
all you do so i mean it's it's not that
hard to understand and so
it's like let's let's use a chair or
let's use a cup let's use a cup all
right
so so a cup is a bunch of stuff
right it's a million things it's a
million aspects it's a there's an
indefinite amount
of aspects to the cup and so it's not a
cup or whatever it is that you're seeing
this thing
this this thing has an has a
has an indefinite amount of
potentialities to it okay
uh and the only and so what makes it
b is its name it's it's naming
it's a cup it has a name it has a
purpose
and therefore you're able to it
jumps out of the not just the chaos of
the actual
object but the chaos and all the chaos
in which it is
joined together right all of this this
chaos
um and so that is
why god creates the world through
word through meaning because meaning is
that which holds
things together without meaning things
dissipate into potentiality they
dissipate into
the million the million aspects of it
that
that that that could be and and it's an
indefinite and when i say that it's like
it's not even
numerable it's like it's it's not it
doesn't have number it's not that like
there are
so many aspects of this there's an
indefinite amount of them
there's no limit to the amount of
aspects to this
to this to this thing um and so
so that's how i hope that helps it's
like it's it's it's it really is how
reality works like reality
is held together by meaning held
together by word by name by
purpose so all right
all right so do i even dare go into the
super chats do i even dare
i will i will and let's see what it
looks like
oh man all right
there are so many super chats all right
let's do this let's do this all right
i'm i'm
i i feel i feel i feel spry
all right okay let me just
okay so let's start at the beginning
okay so so francisco caldis asks do you
see any conflict between neoplatonism
and christianity well
francisco i answered that question hope
you were listening
uh a same again francisco for five euros
you normally praise the medieval times
but
why do you think the church became so
corrupt as to trigger the protestant
reformation
um and so i mean there are plenty of
reasons
it definitely
there's it has it it's not just about
corruption
because corruption isn't
corruption is the cause for
inner reformation right and so it's like
corruption
causes you to want to fix the the
the corruption right fix the problem but
it's it's not really the problem if the
reformation is is it has to do with
with ideas it has to do with ref with
a reforming of the very theology and
structure of the church and
the authority of the church and so it's
more than that
and it and it has to do with changes
that occurred in the late middle ages
in terms of thinking um and
a spirit of of revolution
which came you know
it's hard to pinpoint exactly where it
started but there's a spirit of
there's a there's a contest between the
pope and the kings especially
the king of france so there's a contest
between the pope and the king of france
and there's a there's a search to have
power on the other so you could say that
maybe the it starts with the pope
overreaching
you know onto uh on to kingship
right in terms of the holy roman empire
overreaching onto the holy roman empire
and then the king of france kind of
saying well it's not going to happen to
me
and then trying to put his hand
on the pope and control the papacy and
so this fight
in the west this struggle between
spiritual authority and temporal power
is
is a struggle about how reality actually
works and
once it gets reversed once the king
you know imprisons the pope once the
king
uh you know once the king kills all the
the the templars like all the all the
the monks
that were under the authority of the of
the pope
then it's like things have started to
topple
and once they started to topple then you
get peasant revolts and you get
the other stuff from below kind of come
up because you've lost your
legitimacy and so it just accelerates
and the reformation has more to do with
that in terms of
um a refusal of the authority
um but then also a a breakdown of
of the just the coherence of theological
understanding
which then manifests itself in terms of
princes who use this to take power
and to liberate themselves from uh
from whatever they want to liberate
themselves from
so all right so zed for 6.99
said should i remain catholic or become
eastern orthodox
i know that's a loaded question but i'd
appreciate your insight any insights you
can offer thanks jonathan
um i mean i don't know become orthodox
like i could just show you to me i mean
i
i think you know i i don't know your
story i have no idea what you're going
through i don't know what churches
are are uh around you like what what's
available to you and so it's difficult
for me to answer that
um i mean i can just answer and tell you
that i do believe that
that that orthodoxy has preserved um
the fullness of the the the fullness of
the mystical vision and the metaphysical
pattern which underlies christianity but
but there's a lot of dark stuff going on
in the orthodox church
you know right now so
you know it's not a
it's all falling apart it's it's just
maybe
i mean i and i i'm exaggerating i don't
want to go too far with that all right
all right so m tarlo 215 for 20
have you read camille pages sexual
personae and if you have what did you
think of it no i have not
i haven't read it um i probably will
at some point just haven't gotten to it
it's not like my priority to read it but
i probably will to kind of understand
because she seems to really be at the
crux and the origin of all the
all the madness in terms of gender that
we're seeing happening so
it could be interesting to to get a
sense of this of the
because she's also reacting to it so
it's like she was the spark she was one
of the people who sparked this
this kind of gender revolution but she's
also reacting so there's something
interesting to uh to understand there
um and so luigi says how did the story
of samson tie into the gospel story so
you watched my last
q a and i said that and i said that
samson and christ are very close
there are so many ways i can't go into
every single aspect of the story
of samson and so a way to understand is
that samson is like is like an attempted
christ that doesn't succeed
a lot of the stories in the old
testament are kind of like that either
like they're an attempt to christ it
doesn't succeed so why do i say that
because just like christ samson tries to
join himself with the foreign woman and
so
christ does that too uh but christ
succeeds in a way that doesn't
compromise him so
you could say that samson is trying to
find honey
in the dead lion that's what uh
samson is trying to do and he succeed
but then it turns against him
and then he he is he has his
his hair is taken right his his
extension
his strength is taken by the foreign
woman right which is what solomon warned
about
um which is what solomon warns about
later
that that that's what happened when you
give yourself to the outside
is that you you get dissipated into the
outside that's the problem of the inside
and the outside
i talked about this in the last q a too
in terms of the story of
of uh of uh of jacob's daughter
and uh and hamur and his sons and so
so but but but samson does a bunch of
stuff like he he takes this
the the door of the city and he brings
it to the top of the hill
all right so that's what samson does
samson tries to join the inside and the
outside together
he tries to find a way to join
to join the the the periphery and the
center
but he does it in an awkward kind of
almost funny way like it
like a kind of uh absurd absurd way
whereas christ does it in a successful
way right christ does exactly that
christ
is crucified outside the city while
being declared as king
he the rip he's crucified outside the
city while entering into the holy of
holies
he does all of these these he unites
these extremes together
um but samson does it but doesn't he
just doesn't succeed
and so he kind of points to christ
and there are a whole bunch of other
places where he does he does as well
and he also so sansan also kind of uses
the power of the foreigner against the
foreigner
right that's one of the things that
samson does so he uses the jaw of the
ass
to defeat his enemies right and so
you know this image of um sorry
the image of balaam who is sitting on
the ass
right so balaam this prophet in the old
testament
is sitting on his donkey and he's he's
going to curse israel
and the donkey is moving off of this
he's moving off the road like so the
donkey's moving off the path
um to save him and uh and the donkey
ends up saving balaam
and so this is and he speaks right the
donkey speaks so the speaking donkey
uh the idea of using the donkey to
defeat your enemy
all of this all of this gets resolved
in jesus story and like when jesus
rides on the donkey and to enter into
jerusalem
uh that's what's going on right that's
what's going on is that is that
he is going to join himself to
the to the to this to hammer
like christ is going to join himself to
hammer in a proper way
right not in an improper way not in the
way that
that uh the daughter of of hammer that
his sons raped the daughter of jacob and
then jacob you know
there's this whole uh revenge sequence
that goes about
but christ is is by dying
at the hands of the romans and the jews
um
[Music]
and and as the and also because the
romans destroyed jerusalem which is a
tragic thing but it's part of the story
then
christ nonetheless in secret
you know manages to climb the hierarchy
hidden and take power and then become
you know the one who's thrown in heaven
and then
the emperor converts and rome converts
so
is that enough symbolic uh symbolic
interpretation for you i just
strang about like seven stories together
in
in uh in scripture hopefully that that
helps
all right so v2zui um for five
uh chf says the catholic argument
against orthodox is
you can't know which council is
infallible without the pope and
receptionism is
circular logic what say you
um i
i don't know i don't know what to answer
to that besides that it's
it's like it's one of those things where
you could say
the same like the same thing is that
that
the circularity of the pope declaring
himself infallible
i mean how's that not circular
how is one circular but not the other i
don't i don't know i don't know how you
how you come to that uh interpretation
so
yeah all right so martha emmer says
why is jesus crowned with thorns
specifically
uh is that he is cloaked in death or is
it a division
of the sacred inside and outside so i've
talked about this several times it has
to do with
taking the result of the fall which is
thorns
right god said when you leave the garden
you will you will face thorns
and then turning that into glory he's
turning death into glory
so he's making the result of the fall
into his crown
so yeah
and that's also why that's also why rome
converts
guys it's the same thing the donkey
right so the donkey converts
it's the it's the impure he turns the
impure into his glory
that's what christ does
all right so stephen anderson for 1270
usd what is your opinion on stained
glass icons
i like stained glass images
in their in their proper place they look
weird and
they look weird definitely in in in
orthodox churches where all the walls
are painted
and where you have or you have like
mosaics
i feel like the stained glass doesn't
work there because the color is coming
from the walls and so
if you're gonna have stained glass uh
you shouldn't have like painted walls
because then the
images and the colors coming from the
glass but i mean yeah those
those um those uh windows that shocked
you know or at notre dame where all the
great gothic french gothic cathedrals
especially are just
completely art you could spend your life
looking at those and
and interpreting you know the the
iconography there
so isaac cheatham fortune dollar says hi
jonathan
i had never heard of theosis before but
the tradition came up under
taught victory over sin and attaining
divine nature while on earth
have you heard this language before
cheers
i mean i don't know yeah obviously
theosis
is is is participation it's not
attaining divine nature which is
not really possible or like
participation
divine nature participation is the key
right
we become god by participation in the
life of god
um and so yes it does involve it
involves an
aspect which is beyond even our own
virtue in the sense that by
participating in the sacraments by
taking communion by
being involved in the love this this
mesh of love in the church that i talked
about then we are already
undergoing theosis to a certain extent
but then it ends up being crowned in
this
in this victory over sin victory over
our passions victory
over our distractions and our capacity
to
to see the uncreated light or to see the
glory of god and participate in that
glory so it has to do it does have to do
with this like kind of coming together
right shedding the garments of skin the
way that it's described
um in the in the fathers and then
you know coming into the holy of holies
entering into that secret place
it's a transformation of the person it's
not just a moral
change it's not just a forensic
declaration it's an actual
transformation of the person in all all
their
thoughts their being their you know
their sense of themselves into
into the person of god into the into the
life of the trinity you could say
all right so brian york for five dollars
to the the new testament epistle seems
like a commentary on the symbolic
gospels is this right
if so why do the gospels need commentary
can they not stand alone
um i mean why do they need commentary
can they not stand alone
i i understand what you're saying it's
it's but that's the wrong way of
understanding reality
it's like you could say i could go one
one more
i could say why do we need the gospels
can't we just have christ
right why do we need four gospels
couldn't we just have the direct words
of christ in one
thing like why do we need four and so
it's like
the reason why we not only need or not
need
why we rejoice in the commentary and why
we rejoice in the
commentary of the commentaries that is
the father's commenting
on the commentary and the gospels and
then other fathers
commenting on those fathers who are
commenting on the gospel
and the and you know and the old
testament and
all of this commenting let's say and
this
this participation in each other's works
is part of what the church is in the
sense that it is this
this this this joyful multiplicity right
it's not like there's some like to to
imply for example like
why does the gospel need the commentary
it's almost it really
is misunderstanding what is this
fullness that christ is calling us into
um and and wanting to see it like also
in a puritan way right where it's only
just about
removing the garments of skin uh rather
than thinking that yes
there is an aspect of that but there's
also this idea that christ fills up
the saints fills up the world and fills
up you know fills things up
and so yeah all right so mike mike for
279 cid says i live in darval wish we
could meet
i mean maybe after covid uh you know
it's like
for sure like our church has started
again and so i've been going
pretty regularly to church um
and uh and and now because because there
was only ten people so i was going like
every other week
but now that it's it's up now to we're
allowed to be more
then i'll probably be there a lot and so
if you guys want to go to saint benoit
and you'll see which is my parish
um you know and see an orthodox liturgy
on
uh but you have to reserve though that's
complicated so i probably shouldn't say
that because you're supposed to reserve
your place so sorry about that
but anyways once hopefully if this
coping thing ever ends
then you can always come to church and
i'll be happy to greet you
in montreal all right so carlos vaga for
499 usd says
thanks jonathan for all the content you
bring you seem like you're on top of
things
all the time he invites on overcoming
the spiritual
sin of acidia and so i think i answered
that didn't i answer that about assadia
i mean i would say for sure at least
being aware of it is important
uh and and distinguish you know and kind
of recognizing in us that
feeling like irratible feeling like like
you need to
change like you need to change the
channel you know like you need to
to to to move on to the next thing uh to
just be aware of it and maybe kind of
take a moment of stillness and uh
for sure developing a a uh space
a practice of prayer for sure that's
that helps that's for sure
all right so brandon samuel four five
usd said jordan peterson talks about
a triad of culture and nature immediated
by the individual
is this a microcosm of the pattern of
heaven
earth and man
uh yeah that's a good it's not it's not
a bad way to understand that
if you understand culture as let's say
the patterns
of of uh how society exists together
um and when nature has this potentiality
and then man yeah that's not bad um
all right guys i probably need to end
this all right
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
skip to a few because it's getting it's
getting way too late
so the golden thread for 25 sorry for
those that i have to skip
uh the golden thread for 25 usd david
kaley has a great book out on yvonne
eric
who he covered on his cbc radio show
ilic ideas about life
as an idol and the corruption of
christianity especially through its
relationship to images
are worthy of an interview i mean yeah i
guess i could see that i don't know
about that
um i probably would obviously disagree
with that all right so isaiah
for five dollars usd says can you have
jay dire on your channel
man that's a big question it's like
right now
i would say jay and i i think we're on
good terms at least i'm on good terms
with him
um i don't have a problem with him and
you know i think that i think that i
kind of thank god for all the things
that he's doing i've seen people convert
and i'm seeing that he really has he he
really has a voice in a certain let's
say
area of the internet or an area of
culture
and so i really appreciate that and and
i
like i said i thank god for that and
once in a while like i'll drop a note if
i see something i find interesting
like i'll share his tweets once in a
while as well but at the same time like
i'm not
i don't know like i don't we still did
have this massive thing
and he and and so i it's like
it's like i don't i haven't i don't know
it's for me it's just kind of there
and i'm i'm happy for what he's doing
and i'm happy to see people kind of
uh talk about christianity um but i also
don't have the same approach as him
and the way that i talk about the faith
is very different like he's more
polemical and looking at very technical
questions of
of uh theology which is not i don't do
that and so
and even some of the things that he
talks about to be honest i don't totally
understand like
i'm not gonna hide it i think he really
does have a grasp on very technical
aspects of uh
trinitarian theology and you know the
distinction between nature and
energies and stuff and so and so i'm not
sure
like i don't know it's like i just i'm
not sure that it would be
that our worlds need to really
fit together like in terms of youtube i
think that in prayer like i pray for him
and i
and i pray for the people that that that
that he talks to that they come to
to christ but i may be i i i always had
this idea that it's going to happen one
day but
i'm not in a hurry let's say because
because you know
you know things did get intense between
us and it's fine now but i i
it doesn't necessarily mean that we have
to necessarily have to kind of
to to to come together on youtube you
know i don't know
i'm sure that and we'll see like just me
saying that let's see
what happens like let's see what happens
with a lot of the people following him
like if it's going to
bring about what it's going to bring
about let's just even watch right now
and watch what's going to come out of
just what i said now and see what
happens so
all right guys so i think
i think i have to stop because it's like
11 30. so sorry for the few people that
i missed in the super chats
uh thank you for your time everybody
thank you for
for your attention and uh yeah and pay
attention
if people who are interested in um
learning icon carving like i said it's
coming out
probably next week you'll you'll see me
i might do a like a live stream of me
carving
wood carving and then talk about what
i'm going to do in the
training so look forward to that
everybody thank you for your attention
don't forget to sign up to my uh to my
website as well
and i will talk to everybody next month
so bye everybody